HELLO AND WELL DOWN. WELCOME
EVERYONE SO I WANT TO WELCOME
ALL OF YOU ALL TO OUR FIRST
HEARING FOR THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON INCARCERATED WOMEN
AND I WANT TO EXTEND A SINCERE
THANK YOU TO THE BED CHIU BY
TEMPLE FOR HOSTING AND TO ALL
OF OUR- PANEL BICKERS OUR
WARRIOR WOMEN. FOR TAKING TIME
OUT OF THEIR ADVOCACY EFFORTS
TO BE WITH US. BEFORE I GET
STARTED WITH MY REMARKS I DO
JUST WANT TO CALL OUT I TIANA
JEFFERSON I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE SAY HER NAME.
BECAUSE THIS REALLY IS A SERIES
OF CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW
WOMEN HOWEVER WE SELF IDENTIFY
AS WOMEN ARE UNDERVALUED OUR-
DISCARDED AND ARE MARGINALIZED
BY A SYSTEM NOT DESIGNED TO
LOVE EMBRACE AND HEAL US SO.
SHE WAS KILLED BOTH
UNCEREMONIOUSLY AND WITHOUT
FAVOR AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE SAY HER NAME.
IT'S NO SECRET THAT OUR NATION
IS FACING A MASS INCARCERATION
EPIDEMIC. IF THE PRISON
POPULATION OF THE UNITED STATES
WERE A CITY IT WOULD BE AMONG
THE COUNTRY'S TENTH LARGEST.
THE UNITED STATES SPENDS
APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY BILLION
DOLLARS WITH A B. EACH YEAR ON
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES ALONE A
NUMBER MADE EVEN MORE ALARMING
WHEN COMPARED TO THE SIXTY
EIGHT BILLION DISCRETIONARY
BUDGET OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. HERE IN CALIFORNIA
ALONE WE SPENT NEARLY THIRTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS ON STATE
CORRECTIONS EXPENDITURES.
THOUGH MOST NATIONAL DISCOURSE
AROUND CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM
CENTERS ON THE FEDERAL PRISON
SYSTEM THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE
INCARCERATED PEOPLE ARE HELD IN
FACILITIES CONTROLLED BY STATE
AND BY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. MOST
OF US ARE AWARE THAT PEOPLE OF
COLOR PARTICULARLY BLACK PEOPLE
ARE DRAMATICALLY OVER
REPRESENTED IN THE NATION'S
PRISONS AND JAILS WHAT MANY MAY
NOT KNOW HOWEVER IS THAT THOSE
SAME DISPARITIES ARE
EXACERBATED FOR WOMEN. WHOSE
RATE OF INCARCERATION HAS BEEN
RISING FASTER THAN THAT OF MEN
FOR DECADES. SEVERAL STATES
HAVE TAKEN STEPS TO DECREASE
THEIR PRISON POPULATION AND
WHILE THE INTENTION IS GOOD
THESE STEPS OFTEN FOCUS MORE
DIRECTLY ON MALE PRISON
POPULATIONS WHILE THE NUMBER OF
MEN AND STATE FACILITIES HAS
DECREASED THE NUMBER OF WOMEN
HAS COUNTERPRODUCTIVE LEE
INCREASED. I'M HAPPY TO REPORT
THAT CALIFORNIA IS AMONG ONE OF
THE FOURTEEN STATES WHERE
CHANGES IN WOMEN'S
INCARCERATION ARE ACTUALLY
SLOWING THE GROWTH OF STATE
PARK PRISON POPULATIONS AND
SOMETIMES EVEN DRIVING DE CAR
SERRATION ACCORDING TO THE
PUBLIC POLICY INITIATIVE. BUT
LET'S REMEMBER THAT THAT DIDN'T
HAPPEN BY CHANCE THE SHIFT
TOWARDS THE D. KERR SERRATION
OF WOMEN HAS BEEN MADE POSSIBLE
BY VOICES THAT CARE AND BY
VOICES WHO HAVE BEEN IN THE
STRUGGLE. VOICE IS MUCH LIKE
THE ADVOCATES WE ARE GOING TO
HEAR FROM TODAY. FORMALLY
INCARCERATED WOMEN AND
PROFESSIONALS WITHIN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM SUCH AS
THE JUDGES DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
IN PUBLIC DEFENDERS. PEOPLE WHO
SEE THE GRAVE HARM IN A SOCIETY
THAT SPENDS MORE MONEY ON
INCARCERATING PEOPLE THAN ON
EDUCATING THEM. PEOPLE WHO NOT
ONLY DREAM OF A MORE JUST
SOCIETY BUT TAKE ACTION TO MAKE
THAT DREAM A REALITY PEOPLE WHO
KNOW THAT AS PROGRESSIVE AS
CALIFORNIA MAY BE IN COMPARISON
TO OTHER STATES. IT IS NOT
ENOUGH IT IS NOT NEARLY ENOUGH.
THE NEED TO REVIEW AND REFORM
POLICY SENTENCING AND
REHABILITATION PRACTICES FOR
INCARCERATED WOMEN IS WHY I
DECIDED TO CHAIR THE SELECT
COMMITTEE. MY HOPE IS TO BUILD
A COALITION FROM ALL SIDES OF
THE ISSUE TO EXPLORE. PROBE
MEASURES TO DECREASE THE RATE
WOMEN IN TO SUPPORT THE-
DIGNITY AND REHABILITATION OF
INCARCERATED WOMEN. SO I WANT
TO FIRST THANK THE STAFF BOTH
AT BAT SHOOT VÀ AND MY
DISTRICT IN MY CAPITAL STAFF
FOR HELPING TO PUT THIS
TOGETHER THEY ARE SCATTERED
ACROSS THE ROOM AND HOWARD QUAN
WHO'S MY LEGS DIRECTOR IN THE
BACK LOOKING AT HIS PHONE TO
ISAAC BRIAN OR NEW SENIOR
ADVISER HERE IN THE DISTRICT
OFFICE BALK HE'S A ONE. THE A
LENA EVANS NIKKI JOHNSON I JUST
WANT TO GIVE A SHOUT OUT I'M
MAKING GARRISON AND I'M I WANT
TO BRING UP NOW HERE IT ROSE AT
WHO IS THE FOUNDER OF THAT SHOE
THAT TO SAY SOME WORDS AND TO
WELCOME. US TO THE SPACE SO
THING TO HEAR IT THANK YOU.
WOOD WE'RE VERY HONORED TO
SHARE OUR SPACE IN OUR YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE WITH INCARCERATED
MEN AND WOMEN. THIS IS OUR
SANCTUARY WHERE YOU ARE
SITTING. AND I'LL TELL YOU JUST
VERY BRIEFLY HOW THIS ALL CAME
TO BE. I AM A SOCIAL WORKER BY
EDUCATION BUT I ALWAYS HAD AN
ATTRACTION THE OUTLAWS. AND.
YEAH HI I LIKE BAD BOYS
BASICALLY AND ABOUT THIRTY FIVE
YEARS AGO THERE WAS A AN AD IN
THE PAPER. FOR A SOCIAL WORKER
OF JEWISH BACKGROUND AND
CULTURE TO WORK WITH JEWISH
CRIMINAL OFFENDERS AND I HOPPED
ON THAT AD. WHEN I GOT HIRED
AND STARTED GOING OUT TO A
COUNTY STATE AND FEDERAL PENAL
INSTITUTIONS VISITING
INCARCERATED MEN AND WOMEN AND
THERE WAS NOTHING THAT THE
COMMUNITY HAD TO OFFER FOR RE
ENTRY. AND I GOT REALLY
FRUSTRATED AT SOME POINT OR
ANOTHER AND I SAID WELL SCREW
IT I'M GOING TO START MY OWN.
AND THERE WAS HOMELESS SHELTER
MONEY COMING INTO TOWN ROAD
GRANT FOR A HOMELESS SHELTER
FOR JEWISH MEN AND WOMEN COMING
OUT OF JAILS AND PRISONS AND
THE FIRST WOMAN WHO WE EVER
ACCEPTED IS SITTING RIGHT HERE
CARRY NEWMAN HOW MANY YEARS AGO.
TWENTY THREE YEARS AGO AND HE
NOW DIRECTS OUR ALTERNATIVE
SENTENCING PROGRAM CONTINUING
THE MISSION OF OUR REACH TO
INCARCERATED PEOPLE SO I'M GLAD
THE WORLD HAS CAUGHT UP TO OUR
INTEREST IN THIS MISSION
BECAUSE IT IS A MISSION. THAT
REVOLVING DOOR YOU ALL KNOW IN
AND OUT OF PRISON AND THERE
NEED TO BE MANY MORE PLACES
LIKE THIS WHERE PEOPLE CAN COME
AND HE IS IN COMMUNITY AND WE
WANT TO BE PART OF THIS EFFORT
AND JOIN YOU IN WHATEVER WE
CAN. HELP. THE ASK YOU NOT TO
BE ON YOUR PHONES AND TO PAY
ATTENTION. THANK YOU THERE IT
AND RESTROOMS ARE TO MY RIGHT
BEHIND AND WE DO ASK THAT YOU
PUT YOUR ELECTRONIC DEVICES ON
SILENT OR ON VIBRATE. SO THIS
IS HOW IT'S GOING TO GO WE HAVE
OUR FIRST PANEL HERE OF
WARRIORS. WHO HAVE COME OUT OF
THE SYSTEM WE ARE GOING TO
START FROM MY FAR LEFT IN WORK
TO THE RIGHT ALTHOUGH ALWAYS WE
STAY ON THE LEFT. I WILL NOT
INTRO DO SPOKES BECAUSE I DON'T
WANT TO STEAL THEIR THUNDER AND
WE DON'T WANT TO HAVE
DUPLICATES OF TIME BUT I AM
GOING TO. HAVE SOME TF
QUESTIONS AND SO MAYBE THESE
ARE QUESTIONS YOUR SOARING IN
YOUR TESTIMONY OR IF YOU GO
FREE STYLE MAYBE THERE
QUESTIONS. SECONDS DID YOU KNOW
ANYONE WHO HAD BEEN
INCARCERATED GROWING UP. WHAT
WAS YOUR GUARDIAN SHIP LIKE.
DID YOU SUFFER ANY TRAUMAS THAT
YOU'D LIKE TO SHARE. WHAT WAS
THERE A POINT WHEN THE SYSTEM
FAILED YOU. WAS INCARCERATION
LESS STIGMATIZED OR MORE
NORMALIZED. DID YOU GO TO TRIAL
WERE YOU OFFERED A PLEA BARGAIN
DID YOU FEEL LIKE YOU HAD
ADEQUATE REPRESENTATION. DID
YOU FEEL PREPARED FOR WHAT
INCARCERATION WOULD BE LIKE
PRIOR TO YOUR INCARCERATION.
DID YOU HAVE ADEQUATE TIME TO
INFORM YOUR FAMILY MEMBERS AND
LOVED ONES DID YOUR ARRESTING
OFFICER TESTIFY DID YOU FEEL
THAT YOU RECEIVED EQUAL JUSTICE
UNDER THE LAW. SO FEEL FREE TO
ANSWER ANY OF THOSE QUESTIONS
OR NONE OF THOSE QUESTIONS BUT
FOOD FOR THOUGHT SO THANK YOU.
YOUR TIME YEAH. AND EVERYONE
SHOULD HIT THE PUSH OF A BUTTON
SO THAT THE GREEN LIGHT POPS UP
GOT IT HI MY NAME IS BRITTANY
RICHARDSON I AM AN EMPLOYEE
HERE AT BEACH YUBA AND I'M
FORMERLY INCARCERATED. I LET ME
THINK I DON'T THINK I KNEW
ANYBODY THAT WAS INCARCERATED
WHEN I WAS GROWING UP WE WERE
NOT JAILED PEOPLE MY MOTHER
SAID THAT TO ME A COUPLE TIMES
WHEN. JAIL WE'RE NOT JUST LIKE
ONE ROGUE UNCLE THAT. IT WAS
THIS BIG DEAL THAT HE'D BEEN TO
JAIL AND THEY LIED ALL THE KIDS
AND SAID HE WENT TO COLLEGE FOR
LIKE EIGHT YEARS. BUT SO NO I
DIDN'T I HAD A VERY. SKEWED
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT AND
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUAL WAS OF
WHAT OUR CRIMINAL WAS OF WHAT A
DRUG ADDICT WAS. I AM I AM A
HEROIN ADDICT AND A DRUG ADDICT
I WILL I HAVE ALMOST FOUR AND A
HALF YEARS OF SOBRIETY NOW. I'M
JUST GONNA JUMP RIGHT IN IN
JUNE OF TWO THOUSAND AND
FIFTEEN I WAS ON A LOT OF DRUGS
AND. IN A PRETTY DECENT STATE
OF PSYCHOSIS AND I WAS ARRESTED
WITH A CO DEFENDANT FOR
CARJACKING AND STRONG ARMED
ROBBERY. I WAS INCARCERATED IN
A COUNTY JAIL FOR ALMOST SIX
FOUR MONTHS AND THEN I TOOK A
PLEA BARGAIN SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS I TOOK A PLEA BARGAIN
I PLAYED TO ONE COUNT OF
CARJACKING AND WAS SENTENCED TO
THREE YEARS IN STATE PRISON AT
EIGHTY FIVE PERCENT. OF TO DO
YOU 85% OF MY TIME I AGREED TO
THAT I WAS PLEADING TO A
VIOLENT CRIME AND THAT I TOOK A
STRIKE ON MY RECORD AS PART OF
MY PLEA BARGAIN. I HAD NEVER
HAD ANY KIND OF LAW ENFORCEMENT.
I'D NEVER BEEN ARRESTED I'D
BEEN PULLED OVER LIKE ONCE OR
TWICE THAT I COULD CRAM A WAY
OUT OF SPEEDING TICKETS SO I
DID THAT A COUPLE TIMES. I HAD
A VERY SERIOUS DRUG PROBLEM IF
THERE'S A PLACE WHERE I BELIEVE
THAT THE SYSTEM FAILED ME. IT'S
THAT IT'S IN THAT I. I BELIEVE
THAT I NEED A DRUG
REHABILITATION MORE THAN I
NEEDED TO BE AN EXAMPLE THAT
WAS MADE OF SOMEONE IN THE
COURT SYSTEM I TAKE COMPLETE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR MY CRIME AND
FOR WHAT HAPPENED BUT I ALSO
BELIEVE AND FOUGHT VERY HARD.
TO TRY AND BE SENTENCED UNDER
DIFFERENT DRUG COURT GRANT. AND
ULTIMATELY. HOW TO LIKE TO. NOT
HAVE VERY MUCH CONFIDENCE WHO
AT ONE POINT. SAID TO ME YOU
WERE ON THE NEWS YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO GET A DRUG PROGRAM
BECAUSE IT'LL MAKE THEM LOOK
BAD. AND. I REMEMBER THAT
STICKING OUT AND MY PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ADVICE WAS THE ONLY
WAY TO GET OUT OF DOING A
PRISON TERM WAS EITHER TESTIFY
AGAINST MY CO DEFENDANT WHO WAS
ALSO THE FATHER OF MY CHILD. OR
WELL THAT WAS THAT WAS
BASICALLY IT TESTIFIED AGAINST
MY CO DEFENDANT CLAIM THAT I
HAVE BEEN COERCED LIE
ESSENTIALLY. LIKE I SAID I TAKE
FULL RESPONSIBILITY FOR MY
INCARCERATION BUT I DEFINITELY
SAW SOME FLAWS ALONG THE WAY IN
THE PROCESS OF BEING
INCARCERATED I DID THE MAJORITY
OF MY TIME AT THE CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTION FOR WOMEN IN CHINO
THE LAST NINETY HUNDRED AND
TWENTY DAYS THAT I WAS
INCARCERATED I WAS AT A WOMEN'S
FIRE CAMP FACILITY. IN SAN
DIEGO COUNTY I WAS I HAD. I WAS
VERY LUCKY IN THE WAY THAT I
WAS ABLE TO DO. MY PRISON
SENTENCE IN THAT I DID NOT HAVE
THE EXPERIENCE THAT I SAW OTHER
WOMEN HAVING I NOTICED A
PROFOUND DIFFERENCE IN THE WAY
I WAS TREATED BY. PRISON STAFF
CORRECTIONS OFFICERS AT CETERA
BECAUSE I OFTEN HEARD WHAT'S A
NICE WHITE GIRL LIKE YOU DOING
HERE WHAT YOU KNOW YOU DON'T
LOOK LIKE YOU SHOULD BE IN
PRISON YOU MUST HAVE BEEN
INCARCERATED BECAUSE OF A MAN
THE BIAS WORKED IN MY FAVOR BUT
IT WAS DEFINITELY A VERY STRONG
BIAS. I WAS HEAVILY CONNECTED
TO THE JEWISH WOMEN'S COMMUNITY
IN. AT THE AT THE PRISON IN
CHINO THAT WAS VERY FIRST MIGHT
CARRY NEWMAN THE ALTERNATIVE
SENTENCING DEPARTMENT. AND
EVERY TIME GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY I TALK ABOUT HOW
THAT LADY SAVE MY LIFE BECAUSE
SHE DID. SHE HEARD ME SPEAKING
AT AN EVENT IN PRISON CAME UP
TO ME AFTERWARDS AND TOLD ME
THAT SHE THOUGHT THAT I SHOULD.
SEND IN AN APPLICATION HERE. IN
COMPARISON TO OTHER WOMEN THAT
I WAS INCARCERATED WITH. THAT I
HAVE SINCE WE'VE ALL GOTTEN OUT
AND. NO WE STAY IN CONTACT
THEIR SOCIAL MEDIA AT CETERA I
HAD. AN INSANELY DIFFERENT
REENTRY EXPERIENCE BECAUSE OF
THE RESOURCES THAT I WAS
OFFERED HERE SO I ALMOST FEEL
I'M QUALIFIED TO TALK ABOUT THE
STRUGGLES. IN TERMS OF COMING
BACK IN BECAUSE I CAME TO A
REALLY SAFE PLACE I CARRY IT
TALKED ABOUT TO HEAL AND TO
FIND MY FOOTING. AND HAVE BEEN
PROVIDED OPPORTUNITY AFTER
OPPORTUNITY EVERY TIME THAT
I'VE ASKED FOR IT IN TERMS OF
EDUCATION IN TERMS OF THERAPY I
WAS OFFERED FAMILY
REUNIFICATION I WAS. I HAVEN'T
I HAVE A JOB HERE NOW. THEY
KEEP ME AROUND THEY PROMOTED ME
A COUPLE TIMES I MEAN I WAS
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHOW
THAT I WAS MORE THAN MY CRIME
MORE THAN A PRISON SENTENCE AND
MORE THAN THE VERY WORST MOMENT
OF MY LIFE. BUT I'VE SEEN THAT
STRUGGLE FOR WOMEN THAT I WAS
FRIENDS OR MOTHERS JUST LIKE I
AM. THAT WERE DRUG ADDICTS WHO
NEEDED SOME HELP NOT TO BE
LOCKED UP JUST LIKE I WAS. AND
I'VE SEEN THAT STRUGGLE BE
INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT. FOR WOMEN
THAT ARE IN. YOU KNOW THE STATE
FUNDED PROGRAM WHERE PEOPLE
ARE. YOU KNOW. NOT PAYING AS
CLOSE ATTENTION OR EITHER. IT'S
EITHER TOO RESTRICTED OR IT'S
NOT RESTRICTED ENOUGH OR
EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT IT'S NOT
REALLY A PROGRAMMER YOU CAN
STAY YOU CAN GET A HIGH THERE'S
LONG AS YOU DON'T CAUSE A
PROBLEM I'VE SEEN A LOT IN
TERMS OF. THAT AND I'VE BEEN
LUCKY ENOUGH TO NOT HAVE THAT
HERE. SO THAT'S. I MEAN MY
EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN. A PRETTY
BEAUTIFUL AND IN TERMS OF WHAT
I WAS OFFERED. I'M NOW GOING TO
SCHOOL TO BE. A DRUG AND
ALCOHOL COUNSELOR I PERSONALLY
FEEL. ACTUALLY COMMANDED IT TO
DO THIS KIND OF WORK I READ
THIS TEACHING ONCE AND I TRIED
TO ASK GROW BY ABOUT IT AND-
YOU DON'T REMEMBER I WAS
TALKING ABOUT BUT- I READ THIS
TEACHING ONCE WHEN I WAS
STUDYING WITH RABBI IN PRISON
THAT TALKED ABOUT IF YOU DO
WRONG WITH THIS HAND YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO DO. RIGHT WITH IT.
AND IT'S NOT A MATTER OF LAKE.
I WASN'T A NICE PERSON SO I
NEED TO BE A NICE ONE BUT I
TOOK AWAY FROM THE WORLD IN
TERMS OF DRUG ADDICTION AND
CRIME. AND. I WANT TO GIVE BACK
TO TRY AND COUNTER ACT THAT.
KARMIC BALANCE MAKES SENSE. IS
THAT TIME. OKAY OF I WAS THERE
WILL SINCE KIßM LEAD
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKER AT
SAINT JOHN'S WELL CHILD AND
FAMILY CENTER VERY GRATEFUL TO
BE HERE. AND THE- I LOTS OF A
TISSUE VÀ I'M ONE OF THE ONLY
PEOPLE THAT GRADUATED HERE IN
HANDCUFFS. OF. I FIGURED OUT A
LOT HERE I WAS GIVEN AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GET SOBER HALF
OF MY LIFE I'D SPENT SIXTEEN
YEARS DRUG AND ALCOHOL ABUSING
AND GETTING INTO ALL KINDS OF
STUFF I THINK I'VE BEEN TO JAIL
PROBABLY MORE THAN TEN TIMES
BUT THE LAST TIME THAT I WENT
IT WAS REAL I WAS FACING
FINALLY A FIFTY LIVE SENS. FOR
SOMETHING THAT WAS NOT FIFTEEN
LIFE OFFENSE BUT BECAUSE THIS
TIME I WAS ON MY OWN AND I WAS
AT MY BOTTOM AGAIN OF THAT I
HAD TO FIGURE OUT WHAT I WAS
DOING AND EVERY TIME I WENT TO
COURT. FOR A YEAR I'LL ONLY
THREE ARE LOCKED DOWN IN THE
BAD GIRLS CLUB IN THIRTY EIGHT
HUNDRED. AND EVERY TIME I WOULD
GO TO COURT. IT WILL GET WORSE
LIKE THE CHARGES SEEM TO GET
INSANE IT WENT FROM. A SIMPLE
FIGHT EVERYONE'S OKAY TO. A
SWAT TEAM SURROUNDING THIS
PLACE HUGE GUYS AND THEY'RE
TAKING ME AWAY AND THEY'RE
SAYING OKAY WELL IT WAS AN
ATTEMPTED THIS AND THEN IT
TURNED INTO AGGRAVATED FIFTEEN
TO LIFE A CHARGE THAT. NOBODY
MY PUBLIC DEFENDER DID NOT HELP
ME FILE ONE MOTION DID NOT KNOW
MY NAME AFTER TEN MONTHS OF
FIGHTING MY CASE. AND I WOULD
COME TO COURT EVERY SIX WEEKS
AND I WOULD BE IN FRONT OF A
JUDGE FOR FIVE SECONDS THERE'S
NO TIME TO REALLY EXPLAIN
WHAT'S GOING ON. AND EVERY TIME
I WAS LEAVING. I WENT FROM
YOU'RE GOING HOME IN A AND B.
TO SHOOT BASICALLY ACCEPTED ME
BACK SAID. THIS IS GONNA BE
SOMETHING SERIOUS KERRY WAS ON
THE PHONE EVERY TIME IS GONNA
BE SOMETHING SERIOUS AND WE GOT
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU KNOW
YOU'RE- YOU'RE READY TO COME
BACK AND- I WAS LIKE I AM I'M
READY AND BE TO SHE WAS THAT
YET. OKAY THAT WILL TAKE YOU
BACK. AND THAT DAY. BECAUSE I
NEEDED SOME KIND OF
REPRESENTATION. I HAD A FRIEND
WHO I MET HERE BATES ISSUE BUT
AND HE WASN'T A CRIMINAL LAWYER
HE WAS AN EMPLOYMENT LAWYER BUT
HE WAS LIKE. IF YOU NEED HELP
JUST MAKING A DEAL LET ME GO UP
THERE WITH YOU AND ALL
REPRESENT YOU DON'T WORRY ABOUT
IT BUT WE WANT YOU HOME. AND HE
HE PULLED ME OUT IN THE BACK
AND HE WAS LIKE. SIR YOU'RE
FIGHTING LIFE. WOODY YOU KNOW I
DON'T WANT TO MESS IT UP FOR
YOU. AND SO WHEN I HEARD THAT
MY FRIEND WAS SO SERIOUS ABOUT
THE KIND OF REPRESENTATION THAT
IT NEEDED IN THE FACT THAT I
COULDN'T AFFORD IT. AS THAT OF
MYSELF IN THE COURT ROOM THIS
IS MY TIME TO THEM TEN DAYS TO
TRIAL THIS IS IT. I STOOD UP
AND I FILED THE MARS EMOTION
THESE WERE LIKE JAIL HOUSE
LAWYERS THAT WERE YOU KNOW
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO TELL YOU
LIKE DO THIS DO THAT DON'T DO
THIS DO THAT BUT YOU DON'T
REALIZE THAT IF YOU SAY THE
WRONG THING IN COURT AND MAKE
THE JUDGE OF. THAT THAT'S YOUR
FUTURE. AND I WAS AFRAID BUT I
STOOD UP. AND WITH THE MARS THE
MOTION YOU CLEAR OUT THE COURT
ROOM AND IT'S YOU THE JUDGE IN
YOUR PUBLIC DEFENDER. WHAT IS
GOING ON THAT'S WHAT THE JUDGE
THAT. THE JUDGE MAKES VERY
CLEAR. I AM NOT YOUR FRIEND IN
THIS IS NOT COFFEE TIME. AND
I'M LIKE OKAY JUST LET ME JUST
TELL YOU WHAT'S GOING ON I
DON'T HAVE ANY DISMISSAL. OF
MOTIONS I'M FACING NOW IN A
CHARGE THAT DOESN'T EVEN I'M
STUDYING THE PENAL CODE BOOKS
AND I'M TRYING TO EDUCATE
MYSELF THE BEST AS I CAN. BUT
THOSE BOOKS ARE SO HARD TO
READ. AND IF YOU DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT THIS SUBSECTION
IS IN THIS KIND OF THING COULD
BE OR- OR A DOUBLE CENTER. OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT OR I THINK
STRIKE. BUT BEFORE THAT YOU DID
NOT GET A TRY FOR. THERE'S A
LOT OF THINGS THAT HAPPEN TO
YOU GOING TO TRIAL. DOING THAT
FAST FORWARD THE JUDGE ENDED UP.
SAYING TO COME BACK IN ONE WEEK
WE'RE NOT GOING TO TRIAL MY
CHARGES WERE NOT THE CHARGES
THAT THE DA HAD SAID THAT THEY
WERE THAT I WAS NOW FACING AND
I WAS SENSE OF FOUR YEARS AT
33% I DID A LITTLE TOUR AROUND
PRISON AND I CAME HOME. WHAT
THAT DID WAS INSPIRED ME TO
FIGHT AND TO HELP OTHER PEOPLE
FIGHT BECAUSE THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM IS NOT CHEST AND NOW
THAT'S WHAT I DO I GO AROUND.
SOUTH CENTRAL AND COMPTON AND I
TRIED EMPOWER PEOPLE AND HELP
THEM WITH THEIR FIRST YEAR
REENTRY AND I KNOW WITH THAT
STRUGGLE IS LIKE AND IF IT CAN
HAPPEN TO ME WHO WITH WHITE
PRIVILEGE AND GREW UP IN A VERY
YOU KNOW PRIVILEGED HOME IT CAN
HAPPEN TO ANYBODY AND I'M HERE
TO MAKE THAT CHANGE BECAUSE I
THOUGHT I THINK ALL THESE
WOMEN. I'M SO EXCITED TO HAVE
THIS KIND OF ATTENTION. HI I'M
MY NAME IS NORMA COMPETE ON AND
I AM THE WOMEN AND NON BINARY.
SERVICES MANAGER AT THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION THAT'S ALL
IT'S A LOT. SO AS A- AS A YOUNG
PERSON I FOUND MYSELF IN AN
ABUSIVE RELATIONSHIP. I IT
DIDN'T I DIDN'T GET THERE
OVERNIGHT IT DIDN'T HAPPEN
IMMEDIATELY IT WAS A PROCESS. I
WAS WAY TOO COMFORTABLE WITH
HAVING CHAOS IN MY LIFE. BUT IT
SPIRALED VERY QUICKLY INTO
PHYSICAL VIOLENCE. I VAN BECAME
PREGNANT WITH MY SON. AND WHEN
I BECAME PREGNANT WITH MY SON
HE WAS THE LIGHT AT THE END OF
A TUNNEL. AND I WAS ABLE TO.
SEE CLEARLY BUT I WANTED IN MY
LIFE AND IT IT WAS TO BE OUT OF
THAT RELATIONSHIP. SO I DIDN'T
HAVE ANY TOOLS I DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT TO DO. SO IN MY YOUNG
MESSED UP MINE I MADE A VERY
BAD DECISION THE WORST DECISION
OF MY LIFE. WHEN I WENT TO
SCARE MY SON'S FATHER AND
INSTEAD I SHOT HIM. HI. I WAS
OFFERED A MANSLAUGHTER DEAL.
AND I DID NOT TAKE IT. BECAUSE
MY BAIL WAS SO LOW AT FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS I THOUGHT THAT
THIS WAS LIKE AN EPISODE OF LAW
AND ORDER AND IT BILL WHY THEY
HAD LUNCH IN THE REALIZE I
DIDN'T MEAN TO DO THAT. AND
THAT I NEEDED TO RAISE MY SON.
AND IT WAS ALL GOING TO WORK
OUT. I'M I WAS RELEASED ON BAIL.
AND I HAD MY SON. AND I WHICH A
TRIAL. I'M AND I WAS FOUND
GUILTY OF SECOND DEGREE MURDER.
OF ONE OF THE. STATEMENTS FROM
THE DA THAT REALLY STUCK WITH
ME IS WHEN HE GAVE THE JURY
INSTRUCTION HE SAID DO NOT FIND
THIS WOMAN GUILTY OF
MANSLAUGHTER THE LESSER CHARGE
OF MANSLAUGHTER IS RESERVED FOR
A MAN IN A BAR FIGHT NOT FOR
HER. SO I WENT TO PRISON MY SON
I WAS REMANDED INTO CUSTODY OF
MY SON WAS ABOUT FIVE MONTHS
OLD. AND I WAS ACTUALLY ONE OF
THE FORTUNATE PEOPLE. I HAD
PARENTS WHO TOOK A MAN. AND I
WENT TO CHECK CHAU LESS I'M
FROM LOS ANGELES SO I WENT AT
THAT TIME EVERYONE WENT TO
CHOWCHILLA WHICH IS IN FRESNO.
AND MY PARENTS MY MOTHER'S AN
IMMIGRANT FROM MEXICO AND SHE'S
PRETTY STRAIGHTFORWARD. AND SHE
SAID I JUST WANT YOU TO KNOW
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO
VISIT YOU. YOU MIGHT GET A
VISIT ONCE A YEAR. SO TO BE
SEPARATED FROM THIS FIVE MONTH
OLD. TRIAL THEN TO BE TOLD
YOU'RE ONLY GUESS HIM ONCE A
YEAR WAS. DEVASTATED SO I'D
LIKE THE WOMEN THAT SPOKE
BEFORE ME I STARTED LISTENING
TO EVERYONE AND ACTUALLY TAKING
INTO ACCOUNT WHAT THEY WERE
SAYING AND THEY SAID. WHEN YOU
GO UP TO THIS ROOM THEY'RE
GOING TO ASK YOU WHERE YOU WANT
TO GO AND YOU'RE NOT GONNA HAVE
A LOT OF CHOICES BECAUSE YOU
ARE. A VIOLENT CRIMINAL. BUT
WHAT YOU SHOULD SAY IS THAT YOU
SHOULD TRY TO GET TO SEE AYE W.
LIKE WHAT IS THAT WOULD THAT
MEAN OKAY I'LL DO IT. I'LL DO
ANYTHING NOW. I'M SORRY I
DIDN'T LISTEN TO YOU GUYS SO I.
IN IN THERE THIS WOMAN I DON'T
KNOW HER NAME. AND I SAID SHE
SAID YOU DON'T QUALIFY FOR THIS
YOU DON'T QUALIFY FOR THAT YOUR
POINTS ARE TOO HIGH YOUR
VIOLENT YOU NOTHING APPLIES
TEAL. AND I DON'T KNOW WHERE I
GOT THIS POWER TO SPEAK UP. BUT
I SAID. CAN I GO TO SEE I W.
PLEASE. I NEED TO RAISE MY SON
AND SHE WAS LIKE WHAT DO YOU
WHO DO YOU THINK YOU ARE AND
THEY GET REALLY UPSET WHEN YOU
THINK YOU'RE BETTER THAN
EVERYBODY THERE SO I THOUGHT I
DON'T THINK I'M BETTER THAN
ANYBODY. PUT THAT OUT THERE I
SUGGEST PLEASE LOOK AT MY CASE
FACTORS AND JUST KNOW THAT I
WILL I'M NEVER GOING TO HAVE
ANOTHER CHILD FOR THE REST OF
MY LIFE AND I JUST WANT THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO BE IN THIS
TRIAL LIVE. JUST GIVE ME THE
OPPORTUNITY. US UP I'LL DO
EVERYTHING I'M SUPPOSED TO.
JUST I JUST NEED THE
OPPORTUNITY. AND SHE SLAMMED MY
SEE FILE AND SAID WELL I WROTE
SOMETHING DOWN SO YOU MIGHT BE
ABLE TO SIX OH TWO WHICH IS AN
INTERNAL LIKE APPEAL. AND SO I
JUST STAY QUIET. AND THEN THE
NEXT THING I KNEW I GOT
ENDORSED TO SEE I W. WHICH IS
THE WOMEN'S PRISON IN CORONA.
AND IT WILL LITERALLY SAVED MY
LIFE AND MY SON'S LIFE JUST
THAT SMALL ACT OF KINDNESS THAT
THIS WOMAN DID. SAVE MY LIFE.
AND MY SON. SO MY SON. HE SPENT
HIS WHOLE CHILDHOOD WITHOUT HIS
MOTHER AND WITHOUT HIS FATHER.
BUT THIS KID CAME TO THE
VISITING ROOM EVERY OTHER WEEK
BECAME FRIENDS WITH ALL OF
THESE WOMEN THAT SPOILED HIM
WAY TOO MUCH. BY THE WAY AND HE
REALLY GREW UP IN THIS
ENVIRONMENT THAT HE LEARNED
THAT. NOT EVERYBODY WHO'S IN
PRISON WHO HAS THIS LABEL IS
BAD. BUT THEN NOT EVERYBODY WHO
IS A GUARD WITH THIS UNIFORM IS
BAD OR GOOD. SO HE LEARNED ALL
OF THE STUFF THAT REALLY A
CHILD SHOULD LEARN BUT THAT'S
WHAT ALL WE HAVE. THAT'S WHAT
WE HAD. AND SO THAT'S THAT'S
WHAT WE DID. I WAS ABLE TO COME
HOME THROUGH THE BOARD OF
PRISON TERMS I WAS AT RISK BUT
DENIED TWICE I WAS MY- MY A
PAROLE WITH REVERSE TWICE I WON
IN IN THE LOWER COURT. THEN
WHEN I BY THE TIME I CAME HOME
MY SON ON HIS WAY TO BOOT CAMP.
SO WE MISSED EACH OTHER. I'M
AND MY SON WENT TO AFGHANISTAN
HE CAME BACK WITH THE PURPLE
HEART HE LEFT THE MILITARY AS A
SERGEANT HE IS AN AWESOME HUMAN
BEING. HE HOWEVER I EVER SAID
FOR YEARS AND YEARS WAS I JUST
WANTED TO BE A GOOD MAN I JUST
NEED THIS KID TO TURN OUT TO BE
A GOOD MAN. AND BECAUSE I HAD
SO MUCH SUPPORT FROM THE WOMEN
ON THE- SIDE. AND FOR MY
PARENTS AND. ME BEING ABLE TO
GO TO THERAPY WHICH I GOT SORT
OF NOT ABOVE BOARD I GOT IT
BECAUSE I WORK THERE THIS KID
WAS ABLE TO TURN OUT TO BE THIS
AMAZING HUMAN BEING AND HE'S IN
SCHOOL NOW AND LOL WANTS TO BE
AN FBI AGENT. SO I DON'T KNOW
IF I DID LIKE A REALLY GOOD
JOB. OR LAKE IT THAT IF YOU
NEED SOME THERAPY I'M NOT SURE
BUT WHATEVER. BUT WE NEED GOOD
ONES RIGHT SO. THAT IS.
PROBABLY MY TIME BUT THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS APRIL GRAYSON I AM
EMPLOYED WITH THE YOUNG WOMAN'S
FREEDOM CENTER I AM STATEWIDE
COORDINATOR OVER THE SYSTEM
WARRIORS FREEDOM COALITION. AND
MY STORY IS VERY DIFFERENT FROM
EVERYBODY ELSE. SO I'M GONNA
ADDRESS ABOUT SYSTEMS FAILING I
HAVE TOUCHED EVERY SYSTEM FROM
BIRTH. I HAVE BEEN IN THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM I HAVE BEEN
ADOPTED I HAVE BEEN IN JUVENILE
JUSTICE. I HAVE ONE TIME BEEN
SHIPPED FROM EVERY SINGLE.
JUVENILE HALL BECAUSE THERE WAS
NO PARENT TO COME GET ME AND
THEY USE JUNE WHEN I HALL AS A
FORM OF PUNISHMENT. AND I WAS A
FOSTER CHILD SO. MISSY MY BIRTH
MOTHER MY BIRTH MOTHER WAS
MURDERED WHEN I WAS THREE HOW
WAS ADOPTED AT FIVE INTO A
FAMILY THAT WAS PSYCHOTIC SO
THAT MOTHER PASSES AWAY ONE ON
FOURTEEN MY FATHER PUT ME BACK
IN THE SYSTEM AND FIFTEEN AND I
AM THAN FIFTEEN YEARS OLD IN
THESE DIFFERENT SYSTEMS RUNNING
AWAY GONNA JUVENILE HALL BEING
ARRESTED FOR BEING BLACK I WAS
OUT IN SAN JUAN CAPISTRANO A
MENTAL HOSPITAL AND THEY
ARRESTED ME BECAUSE ULTIMATELY
I WAS. ALL THE FOURTEEN OF US
AND THE OTHER ONES DIDN'T GO
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW THEY WANT
BLACK SO. AT NINETEEN YEARS OLD
SO LET ME BACKTRACK EIGHTEEN
I'M IN THE STREETS AYE
EMANCIPATE I'M ON MY OWN WITH
NO OLD TYPE OF STRUCTURE NO
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW TO LIVE ON
YOUR OWN. AND I STARTED GETTING
INVOLVED IN THE STREETS AND I
NEED A PAN. AND I START TO BE A
PART OF THE SIX WORLD AND- MY
ROLE WAS I WAS ABLE TO. HELP
HIM PICK UP WOMEN AND THAT'S
WHAT I DID AND I WAS EIGHTEEN
AND I WAS HELPING HIM PICK UP
WOMEN AM AND WHAT PEOPLE DON'T
UNDERSTAND ABOUT THIS WORLD IS
THAT IF YOU DON'T PERFORM
YOU'RE GETTING BEAT IF YOU
DON'T PERFORM YOU'RE GETTING BE
AND A MATTER WHAT HAPPENS
YOU'RE GETTING BEAT AND YOU
NEED TO DO WHATEVER IT IS THAT
THEY TELL YOU TO DO. AND COMING
FROM THE BACKGROUND OF LIKE NO
PARENTS NO MAMA NO DADDY LIKE
THAT WAS MY FORM OF LOVE AND SO
THAT'S WHAT I DID I RESPONDED
TO THAT. THE TENSION IN THAT
THAT ENVIRONMENT. SO IT
NINETEEN I GET ARRESTED IN
SACRAMENTO AND I WAS NINETEEN I
COULD HAVE BEEN A WAS TWENTY
SEVEN AND THEY CHARGED ME AS
THE PERPETRATOR OF THE CRIME
THEY CHARGE ME WITH CAMPING A
PANDERING THEY CHARGED ME WITH
ALL THE CHARGES THAT THEY
SHOULD HAVE CHARGED HIM. HE GOT
CHARGED WITH NONE OF MY STUFF
THAT I GOT CHARGED WITH AND I
DIDN'T UNDERSTAND HOW A PERSON
WHO HAD BEEN IN EVERY SYSTEM A
PERSON WHO HAD NEVER EVER HAD A
CHANCE WAS THE VICTIM. BUT NOT
THE VICTIM THE PERPETRATOR. AND
HOW THEY NEVER LOOK AT THIS TO
DO WITH THE THREE STRIKER WHO
HAD BEEN AND EVERYTHING HE'S
ALWAYS BEEN INCARCERATED HOW HE
WAS SOMEHOW. NOT A FAULT FOR
ANY OF THIS. SO AT THIS TIME
THERE REALLY TOUGH ON CRIME THE
TEN TWENTY LIFE LIKE I CAN'T
JUST CAME OUT AND THERE WAS NO
HAD NO ACCESS TO ANYTHING I WAS
OFFERED A PLEA BARGAIN I WASN'T
UNDER THE ANTI TERRORISM ACT.
AND I HAD NO CHOICE BUT TO GO
TO TRIAL EITHER GO TO TRIAL TO
GET TWENTY TWO YEARS SO I WENT
TO TRIAL BY MYSELF PUBLIC
DEFENDER WHO DIDN'T GIVE A ALL
HE TOLD ME WAS PLEAD GUILTY OR
TELL ON THIS DO WELL THOSE OF
YOU WHO HAVE ANY UNDERSTANDING
OF THE STREETS IF YOU TELL
SOMEBODY YOU'RE GOING BACK TO
THE STREET YOU'RE GOING TO DIE
SO EITHER WAY WHEN I HAD
EITHER. IT WAS TELLING HIM TO
GO HOME AND THAT LIVE IN HAVE
A- HORRIBLE LIFE OR STAY TRUE
TO THE SITUATION AND GO TO
PRISON AND HAVE A HORRIBLE LIFE
SO I HAD NO OPTIONS AND SO I
CHOSE TO. WRITE THE SITUATION.
NOW THAT'S THE CHOICE THAT MY
OPTION AND I CHOSE FOR MYSELF.
I WAS SENTENCED TO TWENTY YEARS
EIGHT MONTHS AT NINETEEN YEARS
OLD. I WENT TO PRISON. THE DAY
BEFORE MY TWENTIETH BIRTHDAY ON
A OUR ANIMAL. LOCAL SOME SOCKS
AND SOME CHOCOLATES VERY COLD.
THIS IS A AND THAT'S WHAT I
KNOW ABOUT THAT SITUATION WAS
VERY COLD. AND I DID NOT LIVE A
MODEL LIFE I DIDN'T DO
EVERYTHING THEY TOLD ME TO DO I
WAS VERY ANGRY AND I DID
EXACTLY WHAT I WANTED TO DO IT
IS BECAUSE YOUR- AND I ENDED UP
MAXING OUT AND I DID WILL THEY
ENDED UP GIVING ME LIKE TWO
YEARS BACK ON SOME TIME AT THE-
THE APPELLATE COURT BECAUSE
THEY HAD KEPT. THEY HAD RAN ALL
MY CHARGES LIKE THERE WAS A
POST ABOUT A CONCURRENT BUT
THEY RUN OF CONSECUTIVE IN
THEIR DOUBLE CHARGING ME AND
THEY JUST. THEY CENTERS ME ON
TOP WAS SENTENCED ME ON TOP WAS
SENTENCED ME. AND SO LOOKING
BACK NOW IT PEOPLE LIKE WHEN I
CAME HOME TO MY PAROLE OFFICER
HE WAS LIKE I HAVE DO THEY GET
THREE YEARS FOR WHAT YOU'VE
DONE. AND HERE I AM THE VICTIM
THAT EVEN I WAS THE VICTIM I
THOUGHT I WAS A BECAUSE I CAME
HOME. BUT HERE I WAS THE
VICTIM. DOING TWENTY YEARS IN
PRISON FOR. A CRIME THAT A GUY
WHO WAS ACTUALLY A PAN. GETS
THREE YEARS FOR. SO. I DO MY
TIME I COME HOME AFTER A
SEVENTEEN YEARS. AND I AM NOW
FIGHTING FOR WOMEN I AM NOW AN
ADVOCATE FOR WOMEN WHO HAVE
NEVER HAD AN ADVOCATE. I THINK
A FIGHT SO HARD BECAUSE I NEVER
KNEW I WAS A VICTIM IN A LOT OF
WOMEN DO NOT KNOW THEIR VICTIMS
IN EVEN IS THAT A PRISON. ALL
THE TREATMENT THAT WE
EXPERIENCE A SOUL NORMALIZE
THAT YOU THINK IT IS OKAY FOR
THE EXCUSE MY LANGUAGE YOU
THINK IT'S OKAY BUT ALSO TO
CALL YOU A **** YOU THINK IT'S
OKAY FOR HIM TO SPEND THE DOORS
ON YOU THINK IT'S OKAY FOR
SEXUAL ADVANCES THAT ALL THAT
IS NORMALIZED IT WOULD YOU SAY
SOMETHING ABOUT IT. THEY ALL
GANG UP ON YOU AND YOUR THEN
MAKES IT FEEL HORRIBLE BECAUSE
YOU'RE TRYING TO STAND UP FOR
YOURSELF AND SO COMING FROM
SYSTEMS WHERE IS NORMALIZED
VIEW TO GET TREATED HORRIBLY AS
A CHILD INTO ANOTHER SYSTEM
THAT'S SUPPOSED TO. TREAT YOU A
THIRD TYPE WAY BECAUSE YOU ARE
DEEMED THIS HARD CRIMINAL WHEN
YOU'RE EVEN OF SITUATION SO
WHAT LED UP TO ALL THIS. TO
BEING IN THE CUSTODY OF PEOPLE.
WHO WERE. NOT NICE. NOT NICE SO
TODAY THAT'S WHY FIGHT THE WAY
A FIGHT THAT'S WHY GO ON THESE
PRISONS THAT'S WHY I DO WHAT I
DO THAT'S WHY I WILL NOT BE
QUIET THAT'S WHY I'M GOING TO
SAY WHAT I NEED TO STAY NO
MATTER WHO IS AGAINST AND HOW
THEY FEEL ABOUT IT BECAUSE I
DON'T STATE NOBODY WILL AND THE
SITUATIONS WILL KEEP.
PERPETUATING. THANK YOU. HELLO
EVERYBODY I AM ROBOTS I WORK
FOR THE WOMEN'S FREEDOM CENTER
MY OPPONENTS ARE THEY THEM I
DID FIFTEEN YEARS IN PRISON AND
MY STORIES STARTS LIKE SOME OF
YOU KNOW I'M FROM I'M FROM
COMPTON SOLD BLACK AND BROWN
ADMITTED. WHOLE LOT OF YOU SEEN
GROWN UP ON THOSE EIGHTIES AND
NINETIES WE ALL KNOW ABOUT
CRACKING WHAT HAPPENED THAT
TIME A MY MOM ALWAYS REAL POOR
MY FATHER WAS INCARCERATED YOU
KNOW IT PROTECTING HIMSELF LIKE
TO HIMSELF THAT'S WHAT IT WAS
PROTECT HIMSELF WE SHOT SOMEONE
ALONE I GREW UP THINKING THAT'S
HOW YOU PROTECT YOURSELF
EVERYBODY IN COBB POLICE COME
SHOOT PEOPLE YOU KNOW WE SHOP
AT PEOPLE THE HITCH UP PEOPLE
SO. THAT'S WHAT WAS NORMAL FOR
ME GOING UP AND THAT TIME SO.
MY MOM MOVED OUT OF STATE
BECAUSE SHE WANTED TO GET MY
LITTLE BROTHER AND LITTLE
SISTER AWAY FROM COMPTON. AND
WHEN SHE MOVED OUT OF STATE MY
LITTLE BROTHER. HE MISSED HOME
YOU KNOW YOU HAVE SEPARATE
CIVILIANS IN ORDER FOR THESE
WANTS TO MAKE IT. AND IT DIDN'T
REALLY WORK LIKE THAT YOU KNOW
WE THOUGHT IT WOULD BUT IT
DIDN'T MY BROTHER WASN'T HE
STARTED TO SCHOOL. AND THEY
WERE GONNA REST MY MOM. THEY
TOLD HER SHE HAD TO GO TO COURT
SOLD LIKE YOUR LETTER LIKE MY
MOM WAS SHE DID EVERYTHING FOR
US YOU KNOW SHE STARTED HAVING
KIDS AT FIFTEEN AND SHE WAS OF
A- SINGLE MOTHER OF FIVE FIVE
CHILDREN HER HUSBAND WAS IN
PRISON SO I'M LIKE NO MOM NO AT
THIS TIME I'M YOU KNOW EIGHTEEN
I'M DOING GOOD I HAD BEEN OUT
NOT BEEN IN JUVENILE HALL
ANYMORE AND I'M LIKE MOM I HAVE
TWO JOBS. SEN WITH ME I'LL QUIT
A JOB I HAVE MY OWN APARTMENT
SO MY SO MY LITTLE BROTHER
WOULD NEED AND OF WHEN HE CAME
WITH ME I'M OLDER THAN SCHOOL
NOT AND I MADE SURE I LEFT ONE
OF THOSE JOBS AND I MADE SURE
THAT MY BROTHER WAS GOING TO GO
TO SCHOOL YOU KNOW. AS MY
BROTHER END UP GETTING SHOT L.
MY BROTHER MY COUSIN AND A
FRIEND OF MINE THEY ALL GOT
SHOT WITH A K. AND THE NINE YOU
KNOW AND AGAIN OFTEN COMPTON
YOU. GO BACK IS SOMEBODY'S
GOING TO DIE YOU KNOW SO I.
THOUGHT I WAS PROTECTING MY
BROTHER TO ME THAT'S WHAT IT
WAS SO I WENT AND SHOT THE GUY.
AND I GOT FIFTEEN YEARS FOR
THAT AND- MY SENSE OF GOD I DO
FEEL LIKE THE SYSTEM FAILED ME
BECAUSE OF I NEVER HAD A CHANCE
SINCE I GOT THERE SINCE I GOT
OFF THE BUS I NEVER HAD A
CHANCE LIKE I WAS BE IN THERE
LIKE MANY TIMES YOU KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF TORTURE GOING
ON JUST BECAUSE OF. THE WAY I
PRESENT MYSELF LIKE BE
MASCULINE PRESENT IN IN LIKE
IDENTIFYING AS GNC. I WAS
HARASSED ALL THE TIME LIKE OVER
SOCIALIZE LIKE CRIMINALIZED ME
JUST BEING ME. SOUL I AM THERE
WAS ALSO BECAUSE MY FIRST RIDE
UP FOR HAVING A SUNBURN
IMPRISONED. THAT REALLY DAMAGES
STATE PROPERTY. I HAVE I
COULDN'T GO TO A GROUP THAT WAS
MY FIRST RIDE UP WELL IT JUST
SPIRALED I JUST KEPT GETTING
RIDE UPS AND I NEVER HAD ANY
SELF HELP THERE'S NEVER BEEN
ANY TYPE OF REHABILITATIVE
ANYTHING. OF THAT'S WHAT PRISON
WAS LIKE FOR ME AS ALL THE TIME
SO RESPECT THAT. AND SO THAT'S
MY STORY. BY EITHER ONE OF THE.
CAN I TAKE A. HI EVERYONE MY
NAME IS MIA NORTH AND WITH
ASIAN AMERICANS OF AND JUSTICE
ASIAN CAUCUSES HAPPENED CISCO
THE WHAT COULD I DO THAT I AM A
COMMUNITY ADVOCATE THE WHAT WE
HELP REPRESENTS IMMIGRANTS THAT
ARE FACING TO DEPORTATION THAT
EARLY SITTING IN STATE PRISONS
ARE AN ICE DETENTION FACILITIES
AND OF COURSE MY LIVE
EXPERIENCE AS BEING FOR ME
BECAUSE RATE AS SPENT FIFTEEN
AND A HALF YEARS. IN CHOWCHILLA.
AND I HAVE A LIKE THESE LADIES
THEY'VE EXPERIENCED LEGAL
SYSTEM THEY FELT THE MANY TIMES
FOR MYSELF. HAVING WITH THE
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM IT'S
HORRENDOUS EXPERIENCE AND- MY
BACKGROUND IS LIKE MANY
SOUTHEAST ASIAN REFUGEES API
COMMUNITIES WE'VE COME UP.
BACKGROUND OF FAMILIES THAT
THAT WAR THAT'S THAT GENOCIDE
MY MOM IS THAT YOU KNOW SIDE.
SURVIVOR SHE IS ALSO A RAPE
SURVIVOR IMAGINE A CHILD COMING
TO UNITED STATES WITH A SINGLE
MOM AS FAR. AT THE AGE OF FIVE
YEARS OLD. TWENTY SIMILAR IN
THE COUNTRY THAT YOU HAVE VERY.
BEEN UNDER RESOURCE AND NOT
GIVING ADEQUATE CARE MENTAL
HEALTH FOR MY MOM EVEN FOR MY
STEP DAD WHO SHE MET HE WAS A
SOLDIER DURING THE VIETNAM WAR.
AND CAN YOU IMAGINE MOM AND
STEP DAD IN THE RELATIONSHIP
TOGETHER IT WAS VERY VOLATILE
REALLY VIOLENT SO AS A SIX YEAR
OLD BEING THE ELDEST OF TWO
HALF SIBLINGS. I EXPERIENCE
VIOLENCE WITHIN THE HOMES AND
AS A SIX YEAR OLD TO GO TO
SCHOOL YOU FEEL VERY MUCH
ISOLATED BECAUSE YOU THINK IT
IS THE ONLY THING HAPPENING TO
MY- FAMILY TO MY MOM. AND SHE
DID AS YOU KNOW AS SURVIVORS
THE SEEK OUT HELP FROM FRIENDS
FROM LOVE ONES. FROM CUNY BUT
THEY TELL THEM. IN A WHAT DID
YOU WRONG GO BACK HAVE CHILDREN
TOGETHER WELL MY TO BELIZE XR
TWO ACCEPTED AND THAT BECAME
NORMAL FOR ME. THAT IF MOM IS
OKAY THEN YOU KNOW I'M STUCK ON
MY CHILD I HAVE NO VOICE NO
WORDS BE THAT GOOD CHILD. AND
GO TO SCHOOL. I DID EVERYTHING
RIGHTS RIGHT I WAS A GOOD.
SISTER TO. MY SIBLINGS. BUT
AGAIN I DIDN'T KNOW WHO I WAS I
WAS VERY SHAME OF MY CULTURE.
OF IDENTIFYING COLLECTED WHO
WHAT IS IT WHO IS LEAH HOW CAN
SHE RELATE TO. PEOPLE IN SCHOOL
THAT HAVE NO UNDERSTANDING OF
THE LIFE THAT SHE WAS GOING OUT
TO RIGHT COMING FROM A P. I AM.
REFUGEES BACKGROUND AND BY THE
TIME. I WAS SEVENTEEN I DID WAS
NOT VERY SIMPLY. SHIPS TO ME
WHAT WAS A MODEL FAMILY WAS
SOMETHING WATCHING FROM LIKE
FULL HOUSE RIGHT THAT WAS LIKE
A FAMILY I WANTED THAT I COULD
HAVE. AND I END UP.
UNFORTUNATELY HAD NO SALT
SOLIDIFY RELATIONSHIPS AND IT
MEETING MY CO DEFENDANT MIGHT
BE IS A WHEN I WAS SEVENTEEN.
AND SHORTLY WEEKS AFTER BEFORE
AFTER I TURN EIGHTEEN HE BECAME
IN A JEALOUS RAGE WHEN I FIND
INTEREST IN SOMEONE ELSE. AFTER
HE HAD BEEN RAPED ME HE FORCED
ME TO CONFRONT MY VICTIM
THEREFORE I WAS NOT THE MAIN
PERPETRATOR HOWEVER WHEN I WAS
ARRESTED I WAS. PRESSING LAW
ENFORCEMENT TRUST IN THE POLICE
THE END UP CHARGING ME WITH
FIRST DEGREE PREMEDITATION
MURDER LINE WEIGHT I WAS
SENTENCED AT TWENTY YEARS OLD
TO TWENTY YEARS TO LIFE WITHOUT
POLICY PEARL. GOING TO PRESENT
IT TOOK ME ABOUT SIXTY SEVEN
YEARS TO SAY THAT I DID NOT
WANT MY VICTIMS DIE I DID NOT
WANT HIM TO DIE I WAS
PROTECTING MYSELF OUT OF FEAR
FULL WHAT WHAT I FELT THAT HE
WAS OMITTED THAT HE WAS NOT
GOING. TO YOU KNOW THAT NO ONE
WAS GOING TO BELIEVE ME AND
WHEN I DEBTS TELL MY STORY THAT
HAPPENED A TURNOUT BACKFIRED ON
ME WHAT AND UP IN THE PRISON
SYSTEM. VIRTUALLY I WAS ABLE TO
GET MY CONVICTION MY A LOT
VACATED HAD A SECOND WE TRIAL
BUT I WAS SENTENCED TO FIFTEEN
YEARS TO LIFE. BY AND I DID
WANT TO BOARD OF I'M THRILLED
GOVERNOR POLICE I WENT TO BOARD
HEARINGS THE FIRST BILL WAS THE
NOT BECAUSE THE COMMISSION THAT
DID NOT FELT THAT I WAS A
BATTERED WOMAN THAT I BLAME MY
ABUSE ON I'M NOT TAKING
RESPONSIBILITY. WHICH. IS NOT
LONG ENOUGH WEARING MY APPEAL.
HOWEVER. ONE IS A LIKE MAJORITY
OF THOSE THE END UP IN PRISON
95% OR TV SURVIVORS OF SOME
SORT OF SEXUAL ASSAULT. AND
PLACING THEM IN PRISON AND
CAUSE MORE TRAUMA TO THEM. ONTO
THEIR FAMILIES BECAUSE AGAIN
LIKE MY FAMILY MACINNES DOING
TIME WITH ME. AND WHAT REALLY I
DIDN'T REALIZE THAT I HAD FACE
IMMIGRATION CONSEQUENCES I
THOUGHT AS A PERMANENT RESIDENT
THAT I WOULD OFFER PROTECTION
IT WAS UNTIL THREE YEARS FOR MY
POOR. PAROLE BOARD HEARING. AND
THEN WHEN I WAS PICKED UP BY.
AYE AYE. FIVE DETENTION FOR SIX
MONTHS THE ONLY REASON WHY I'M
HERE TODAY BECAUSE- THE- THE
IMMIGRATION JUDGE BELIEVE THAT
AS A SURVIVOR THAT THE
CAMBODIAN GOVERNMENT CANNOT
PROTECT ME FROM THE DEATH
THREATS. OF MY ABUSER AND- AND
HIS FAMILY. BUT TO SAY I THINK
REFORMS HAVE TO BE DONE NOT IN
THE CRIMINAL. NOT IMMIGRATION
REFORM AND ALSO WITHIN THE
STATE REFORM AS WELL TORRANCE
FROM JUST BEFORE. BECAUSE THESE
TWO THERE ARE VERY INTERSECTED.
IF WE WANT TO HAVE A QUICK IT
EQUALITY EQUITY FOR ALL. DO
NOT. DO NOT ALL. ALSO INCLUDE
IMMIGRANTS AS WELL BECAUSE-
IMMIGRANTS HAVE SERVE TIME THE
SERVER TIME WHY SHOULD THEY- BE
CONTINUE CRIMINALIZE FURTHER
RIGHT. THERE ARE OF LOSS OF LOS
FANS TO VERIFICATION SYSTEM OF
AUSTRIA MEMBERS. THIS IS THE
ONLY HOME THAT WE'VE NOTICES
PRO CHILDREN. AND WHEN THEY
WENT TO THIS IS THAT THEY WERE
NOT TOLD THAT. THEY WERE THEY
WERE GOING TO FACE IMMIGRATION
CONSEQUENCES. RIGHT AND I THINK
PEOPLE SHOULD HAVE A CHOICE OF
BEING ABLE TO SAY WHETHER THE
ALONG. WITH WHERE THEY SHOULD
LIVE. AND I THINK AS LIVING FOR
THAT IF CALIFORNIA IS A LEADING
STATE IMMIGRATION REFORM AND-
AND- LEAVING A SECOND CHANCES
THAT DO NOT. DISCLOSE
IMMIGRANTS LIKE MYSELF AND
OTHERS BECAUSE RIGHT NOW I'M
STILL CITY LEVEL I CAN BE
PICKED UP ANYTIME AND- THE
DEPORTATION PROCEEDINGS CAN
START. THOUGH WE APPLIED THE
GOVERNOR FOR IT'S PUTTING AB
THIRTY TWO TWO AND PRIVATE THE
TO AND THE PRESS THE STUMP BUT
YET. CALIFORNIA SEES OUR NEED
TO STOP COLLABORATING WITH ICE
WITHIN THE SYSTEM. TO NOT HAND
OVER THOSE HAVE SERVED TIME
OVER TO I. TO SAY WHAT WE
TOWARDS CAN WE HAVE TO PROTECT
OUR IMMIGRANTS THAT WE SPENT
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS SIX SIXTEEN YEARS I
SPENT PRISON. AND THEN IT'S A
POP PROCEEDED TO POINT ME TO A
COUNTRY THAT HAD NO TIES TO. I
THINK THIS IS WHERE THE
CONVERSATION IS TO START WITH
THE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS WELL THE
COMMODE JUST BEFORE. THANK YOU.
ALSO WAS ARE ALSO ON THAT
BECAUSE I GOT SO EXCITED. SO
PROPOSAL CONVICTION RELIEF FOR
SOMEONE LIKE MYSELF THE
ALTERNATIVE IS PARDONS.
PARTICIPLES WILL OPEN
IMMIGRATION PERSONS. FILE AND
THE GOVERNOR'S PARTY WILL STOP
MY DEPORTATION AND GIVE ME A
RIDE TO GET MY GREEN CARD BACK
OVER TOWARDS YOU YOU KNOW SAYS
A SHIP SO I CAN YOU KNOW NOT
HAVE TO APPLY FOR A WORK PERMIT
AND NOT FEEL LIKE I HAVE TO
LEAVE THE COUNTRY NOT BE ABLE
TO COME BACK. THOSE ARE TURNED
IS ALSO WE ENCOURAGE PUBLIC
DEFENDERS AND DA'S TO WORK WITH
TO GET TO VACATE THEIR SENSES
TO BE NOT THE PORTABLE THAT
THOSE ARE POLLS ALTERNATIVES
FOR THOSE THAT ARE FACING THE
PARTITION LIKE MYSELF. THANK.
HI MY NAME. AND IS THE BUTTON
OKAY. MY NAME IS INGRID ARCHIE
AND I WORK AT IN THE WAY OF
LIFE REENTRY PROJECT I AM
FORMALLY INCARCERATED I GREW UP
IN SOUTH CENTRAL LOS ANGELES MY
MOTHER WAS A DRUG ADDICT MY DAD
WAS A DRUG DEALER MY HOME WAS
VERY VIOLENT. MOST OF MY FAMILY
MEMBERS WERE INVOLVED IN GANGS
ON MY MOM AND MY DAD'S SIDE
SELL EVERYBODY IN MY FAMILY WAS
HUSTLERS AFFAIRS ENTERED INTO
THE SYSTEM AT THE AGE OF SEVEN
I WAS TAKEN AWAY FROM MY MOM
FOR CHILD ABUSE AND MY DAD WAS
NOT ABLE TO TAKE CUSTODY OF ME
BECAUSE HE HAD A MARIJUANA
CONVICTION ALTHOUGH MARIJUANA
IS NOW LEGAL RIGHT. SELL ON. I
WAS ADOPTED AT THE AGE OF
EIGHT. ON I SPENT ABOUT TEN
YEARS AWAY FROM MY MOTHER AND I
DON'T KNOW WHETHER SHE WAS DEAD
OR ALIVE AT FOURTEEN SHE CAME
BACK INTO MY LIFE I BECAME VERY
ANGRY WITH HER BECAUSE I
COULDN'T UNDERSTAND WHY SHE WAS
GONE ON FOR SO LONG IT WAS
BECAUSE OF HER DRUG ADDICTION
AND A LOT OF SHAME AND GUILT
BECAUSE SHE HAD ALLOWED ME TO
GO TO THE SYSTEM AND BECOME
ADOPTED OUT. I ENTERED INTO THE
JUVENILE SYSTEM AT THE AGE OF
FOURTEEN. AND I WAS CHARGED
WITH ASSAULT AND BATTERY IS TOM
PETTY DEATH ON BECAUSE OF LAKE
CALLED ME THE A WORD AND WE
JUMPED HIM. AND I WAS THEY
WANTED TO SEND ME TO WHY A FOR
MY FIRST TIME INSTEAD OF TO SEE
WHY I WAS SO ANGRY THEY WANTED
TO SEND YOU TO A YOUTH PRESENT.
FORTUNATELY I WAS ABLE TO I
ALSO RAN AWAY AT THE AGE OF
FOURTEEN AND SO I ENTER BACK
INTO THE DCFS SYSTEM AFTER
BEING ADOPTED. AND I ENDED UP
WITH IN A PLACEMENT WITH A LADY
WHO WAS FRIENDS WITH THE JUDGE
DOOR AND AT THE TIME WHO IS THE
JUDGE IN INGLEWOOD AND HE
DIDN'T SEND ME TO PRISON HE
GAVE ME A BREAK. FORTUNATELY. I
SAW CYCLE IN AND OUT OF THE
JUVENILE HALL FOR I THINK UNTIL
I WAS EIGHTEEN ON AT THAT POINT
I STARTED SELLING DRUGS AND I
WENT TO THE COUNTY FOR THE
FIRST TIME FROM THERE ARE
PRETTY MUCH WAS IN THE STREET
SELLING DRUGS ANALYST. I WAS A
PART OF THE GAY CULTURE. I
DIDN'T REALLY HAVE LIKE A WHOLE
LOT OF A WHOLE LOT OF ROLE
MODELS YOU KNOW TO SAY YOU KNOW
DON'T GO THAT ROUTE TAKE THIS
ROUTE IT WAS MORE OR LESS THEY
WANTED TO YOU KNOW I HAD I HAD
A SKILL SET YOU KNOW I DIDN'T I
WASN'T IN THE STREETS AND I
DIDN'T WANNA CONFORM TO LIKE
CELL IN MY BODY OUR TO HUSTLE
BECAUSE I THOUGHT I SAW IN CELL
I TRACKED THE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT PEOPLE BECAUSE I HAD
THAT SKILL OF HUSTLING. ON AND
THEN THAT JUST KINDA GRUEL AND
TO ME COMMITTEE MORE MORE
CRIMES. I ENTERED INTO THE
PRISON SYSTEM. AT THE AGE OF
TWENTY I THINK TO. MY CHARGE
WAS A GAME I HAD A GAME CHARGE
A GUN CHARGE IN A POUND OF
MARIJUANA. NONE OF IT WAS MINE
BUT I TAKE THE CASE BECAUSE- I
WAS RAISED TO. BASICALLY IF
YOU'RE COLLISON ASK YOURS AND
YOU RIDE IT OUT. CELL I THAT
WAS MY FIRST PRISON SENTENCE.
AND TWO THOUSAND AND SIX I
BELIEVE I CAME HOME I FIRST MET
SUSAN BARTON. OUT WITH TO HER
HOME SHE YOU KNOW KIND OF
OPENED HER ARMS TO ME. I HAD A
FIVE YEAR OLD CHILD AT THAT
TIME. AND I WENT THROUGH YOU
KNOW I WENT TO OUR HOUSE I GOT
AN APARTMENT. IN TWO THOUSAND
NINE I WAS LAID OFF FROM FOR
RISING BECAUSE I HAD A
CONVICTION ON MY RECORD FOR
SELLING DRUGS. AFTER I HAD
WORKED THERE FOR SIX YEARS. AT
THAT POINT I STARTED COMMITTING
CRIMES AGAIN BECAUSE I NEEDED
TO SURVIVE. TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN I'D KATA I WAS IN AN
ABUSIVE RELATIONSHIP I FLEE
FROM THE ABUSIVE RELATIONSHIP
AND I CAUGHT A CHARGE FOR CHILD
ENDANGERMENT I LEFT MY YOUNGEST
DAUGHTER IN THE CAR ON I TOOK
MY LITTLE CHILD WHICH WAS TO
LET THE TIME INTO THE STORE TO
BUY PAMPERS I WAS OVERWHELMED I
WAS GOING TO POST PARTUM
DEPRESSION WHICH I HAVE WASTE
OVER AND OVER TO THE SHELTER
THAT I WAS AND I WAS FLEEING
FROM MY ABUSIVE RELATIONSHIP
THAT I NEEDED HELP. ON THEY
TOLD ME I NEEDED TO FIGURE IT
OUT SO THAT DAY I WENT TO JAIL
THEY TOOK MY KIDS WE ALL WENT
TO JAIL THE CAR WENT TO JAIL MY
KIDS WENT TO JAIL AND I WENT TO
JAIL. THE NET I THINK PROP
FORTY SEVEN HAD CAME AROUND.
AND IT WAS JUST SO HAPPENED I
WAS ALREADY ON PROBATION FOR A
AT THAT CHARGE. AND THEY READ
THE THEY RAN THE ON. THEY RAN
THE CHILD ENDANGERMENT CHARGES
THAT THAT CHARGE TOGETHER BUT
THE PUBLIC DEFENDER SAID THAT I
DESERVE TO GO TO PRISON CELL
THEY ENDED UP SENDING ME TO
PRESENT THE DAY BEFORE PROP
FORTY SEVEN PASSED. SELL OUT
WAS I WENT TO PRISON I
ADVOCATED MYSELF FROM MYSELF
EIGHT MONTHS LATER AND I WAS
ABLE TO GET OUT ON PROP FORTY
SEVEN. IN THE WAY. ON I CAME
BACK TO A NEW WAY OF LIFE ON MY
DAUGHTER WAS HAVE BEEN MOLESTED
WHILE I WAS IN PRISON BY THE
PEOPLE WHO I PLACED HER WITH.
AND THAT'S WHEN I MET
CALIFORNIA'S FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE ALL AT THE SAME TIME. I
TELL MY STORY A LOT ON HOW I
CAME HOME ON HOW I WAS ABLE YOU
KNOW TO JUST KEEP A LEVEL HEAD.
EVERY NIGHT BACK WITH MY KIDS
CELL WHILE I WAS DOING GOOD
WORK I WAS FIGHTING FOR MY
KIDS. AND FIGHTING THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM AS WELL BECAUSE
MY DAUGHTER HAD BEEN MOLESTED.
AND I HAD TO FIGURE OUT IF I
WAS GOING TO KILL HIM OR IF I
WAS GOING TO ALLOW THE SYSTEM
TO YOU KNOW. DO WHAT THEY
NEEDED TO DO AND SO I CHOSE THE
LATTER BECAUSE MY DAUGHTER
NEEDED ME MORE THAN THE PRISON
SYSTEM DATE. EIGHT MONTHS LATER
I WAS REUNITED BACK WITH ALL OF
MY CHILDREN. I BECAME EMPLOYED
AT IN THE WAY OF LIFE AS THE
PROP FORTY SEVEN SPECIALIST.
FROM THEN I BECAME A CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT COORDINATOR WHERE I
STARTED TO GO OUT TO THE
COMMUNITY AND TRAIN PEOPLE
ABOUT DIFFERENT MEASURES THAT
WILL PASS. THAT WOULD BE ON THE
BALLOT. FROM THEN WOMEN
ORGANIZING FOR JUSTICE NEEDED
LEAF FACILITATOR WHICH IS TO
TRY AND WOMEN ON THE DCFS
SYSTEM. SO A LOT OF TIMES WE GO
THROUGH THINGS IN OUR LIFE AND
WE WONDER YOU KNOW WHY. MY KIDS
WERE TAKEN AND I WENT TO HELL
BECAUSE GOT WANTED ME TO
FACILITATE A GROUP OF WOMEN.
WHO WILL BECOME LEADERS WHO
WOULD FIGHT AGAINST. THE CFS AT
THIS TIME. ALSO I SIT ON THE-
SECOND CHANCE COMMITTEE FOR
CALIFORNIA'S FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE AND IF YOU GUYS KNOW
ABOUT TIME DONE. WE BARF TIME
DONE AND WE JUST PASSED A LOTS
IT EXPLAINS A MILLION
CONVICTIONS IN CALIFORNIA.
CURRENTLY WE'VE BROUGHT IN THE
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT I'M OVER THE
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT APARTMENT SO
NOW I HIRE PEOPLE TO GO OUT
INTO THE COMMUNITY AND I GO TO
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS TO ALSO
TRAIN OTHER PEOPLE I BECAME THE
FIRST PERSON IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
MY MARIJUANA CONVICTION CHANGE
UNDER PROP SIXTY FOUR TO A
MISDEMEANOR AND NOW ADVOCATE
NOT FOR THE USE OF IT BUT THE
CRIMINALIZATION PART AND THE
FACT THAT IF PEOPLE SEE MY FACE
THEY UNDERSTAND THAT IT WORKS
AND THEY COULD BE ABLE TO GET
THEIR RECORDS CHANGE. I'M HERE
BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE I MORE THAN
QUALIFY FOR THE SPACE. ON. AND
I JUST FEEL LIKE IT'S NOT
ENOUGH PEOPLE AND I'M GOING TO
BE INTENTIONAL IS NOT ENOUGH
BLACK WOMEN. THAT THEY SEE THAT
ARE AT THE FOREFRONT OF THE
SPACES AND I FEEL LIKE BECAUSE
I WENT THROUGH SO MUCH THAT I'M
SUPPOSED TO STAND AS THE GAP IN
BETWEEN SO THAT WHEN WE CAN
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY COULD GET
A CROSS THAT BRIDGE WHEN THEY
LAND IN THOSE BATES. AND A
FEELING HOPELESS IN A FILM LIKE
THEY CAN'T. ON THEY CAN'T GET
UP OR THEY FEEL LIKE THEY NOT
GONNA GET THEY KEY IS BACK I
FEEL LIKE THEY NOT DON'T GET
THAT DREAM JOB I FEEL LIKE
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
DREAM AGAIN BUT THEY SEE THAT I
WENT THROUGH ALL THAT. AND I
STAND HERE NOW CELLS THEY COULD
YOU KNOW HAVE THAT HOPE THAT
THEY NEED. TO MOVE FORWARD.
WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU. FOR
YOUR STORIES AND YOUR
RESILIENCE BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
ALL OF YOUR TESTIMONIALS REALLY
ARE ABOUT WE HAVE ABOUT FIVE
MORE MINUTES FOR THIS PANEL AND
BECAUSE IT IS A HEARING WE HAVE
A PARTICULAR FORMAT BUT I WOULD
ACTUALLY LIKE TO INVITE. THOSE
OF YOU ON THE DÍAS WITH ME TO
CROSS EXCHANGE SO IF THERE WAS
A QUESTION THAT YOU WANTED TO
ASK ONE OF YOUR FELLOW FEMALE
WARRIORS. OR GENDER NON
CONFORMING WARRIORS. OR IF
THERE WAS SOMETHING THAT STRUCK
YOU THAT SOMEONE SAID I WOULD
LIKE TO INVITE IN EXCHANGE ON
THE DÍAS FOR THE NEXT FIVE
MINUTES BECAUSE ALL OF THE
STORIES ARE DIFFERENT THE WOMEN
ARE VERY DIFFERENT WE WERE VERY
INTENTIONAL ABOUT MAKING SURE
THAT WE HAD A RAINBOW OF
EXPERIENCES SO THAT FOLKS CAN
GET A SENSE OF THE DIFFERENT
KINDS OF TREATMENT SO I WANT TO
STEP BACK AND LET YOU ALL
CONVERSE FOR THE NEXT FIVE
MINUTES IF THAT'S OKAY. I'M A.
YEAH ONCE AS MAYBE CAN YOU HEAR
ME YEAH MANY APRIL BECAUSE LIKE
I KNOW FOR MYSELF APRIL LIKE I
BELIEVE THAT I'LL BE BACK IN
PRISON RIGHT NOW IF I WASN'T
WORKING LIKE FOR THE CENTER
LIKE THAT'S WHAT IT'S LIKE MY
COMMUNITY THAT KEEPS ME
GROUNDED AND IT'S LIKE SKIN
TAKES OUR COMMUNITY TO HEAL OUR
COMMUNITY BUT LIKE I DON'T GET
TO SEE YOU AS MUCH BUT LIKE DO
YOU FEEL THE SAME LIKE I LOVE
YOU BUT I GUESS THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE NEVER REALLY
TALKED ABOUT SO I JUST WANT TO
ASK YOU BECAUSE I SEE THE
CHANGES. WITH YOU BEING AT THE
CENTER WITH OUR. FOLKS AND I
JUST WANT TO ASK YOU. IF YOU
FEEL THE SAME. SO I WAS GOING
TO CLARIFY. I LOVE YOU I LOVE.
AND SO WHAT I'M WHEN I HEARD
YOU SAY IS THAT THE CENTERS
WITH KEPT YOU FREE YEAH. AND
YOU'RE WONDERING IF I FEEL THE
SAME I USE THE ONE I'M CLOSEST
IS ON DISPLAY LIVE AS OVER I
APPRECIATE YOU FOR TAKING A
STEP TO KICK THIS OFF. I THINK
WAS KEEPING ME FREE IS SO
BEFORE I GOT TO THE CENTER I DO
HUMAN TRAFFICKING WORK ALSO.
AND SO MY PAROLE A TO SO LET ME
SAY THIS. I WASN'T. COMMUNITY
WORK I MET LIKE BESIDE LIKE THE
CENTER BUT AND COMMUNITY YOU
KNOW SO. WELL I THINK THAT.
WALKING INTO A PLACE THAT
UNDERSTANDS LIKE COMING INTO
THE HUMAN TRAFFIC ORGANIZATION
IN THEM SEEING THE VICTIM THAT
NOBODY HAD EVER SAW. AND THEN
ALLOWING ME TO IDENTIFY WITH
THE FACT THAT THERE WAS A
VICTIM THERE THAT THE SYSTEM
HAD DONE ME SO WRONG. AND
EMPOWERING ME TO. STAND IN THAT
POWER IN THAT TRUTH I THINK
THAT. WOULD HELP ME STAY FREE
IF SOMEBODY FINE SAND. BY THE
SECOND. YEAH THEY **** YOU
OVER. AND I THINK THAT'S THAT'S
NOT IT IS BRUTALLY HONEST LIKE
I HAVE NEVER HAD A FAIR CHANCE
EVER. AND SO COMING AROUND
PEOPLE WHO. IDENTIFY WITH ALL
PARTS OF YOU NOT JUST THE PART
THAT THEY WANT TO SEE. I THINK
THAT'S WHAT HELPS ME STAY FREE
AND THEN KNOWING THAT THERE'S
SO MANY PEOPLE. DOWN LEXULOUS
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T LIVE THE
MODEL LIFE SO FOR THEM TO SEE
US OUT HERE THE PEOPLE WHO WERE
FIGHTING IN WHO WERE IN THE
RIGHTS AND WHO WERE DOING ALL
THE THINGS I THINK ESTÁ. I
JUST. THAT WAS ME BUT NOW. WHEN
I SAY IT IS FOR THEM TO SEE THE
PEOPLE WHO THEY THOUGHT COULD
MAKE IT MAKE IT. IT MAKES ME.
MAKE SURE THAT I STAND IN ALL
OF THIS TRUTH BECAUSE I WANT
THE PEOPLE WHO DON'T THINK THAT
THEY CAN COME HOME. WE DON'T
THINK THAT THEY CAN BE RIGHT OF
FREE. TO BECOME WRITER FREE SO
THEY CAN COME HERE OUT HERE
WITH US INTO WHAT WE DO. I
THINK THAT'S WHAT. KEEPS ME. SO
GROUNDED IS THE PEOPLE THAT WE
LEFT. YES I FEEL. I THINK
SOMETHING REALLY IMPORTANT WAS
SAID THAT. KIND OF ENCAPSULATED
EVERYTHING WE WERE ALL KIND OF
TRYING TO SAY SOMEONE DOWN
THERE I'M SORRY I DON'T
REMEMBER WHO MENTIONED GETTING
A WRITE UP FOR HAVING A SUNBURN
BECAUSE IT WAS YEAH BECAUSE IT
WAS DESTRUCTION OF STATE
PROPERTY. AND I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO SOMEHOW
HIGHLIGHTING EMPHASIZE THE FACT
THAT. YOU CAN BE AWAY FROM YOUR
FAMILIES AND YOUR LOVED ONES
AND YOUR CHILDREN FOR
POTENTIALLY A LONGER PERIOD OF
TIME BECAUSE YOU GOT A SUNBURN
BECAUSE YOU'RE STATE PROPERTY
AND YOU'RE NOT MORE THAN THAT
AND I THINK THAT THE WAY THAT
THE SYSTEM FAILS PEOPLE IS THAT
YOU GET PUT INTO A SYSTEM THAT
DOES EVERY SINGLE THING IT CAN
TO REMIND YOU THAT YOU DON'T.
HAVE A RIGHT TO CONNECT TO YOUR
OWN HUMANITY. ANY TYPE OF
REHABILITATIVE WORK THERAPY
GROUP PROCESSING ALL OF THOSE
THINGS ARE BROUGHT IN BY PEOPLE
WHO VOLUNTEER THEIR TIME NOT BY
THE STATE PRISON SYSTEM ITSELF.
IF YOU'RE NOT IN AN AREA IN A
PRISON THAT'S EASILY ACCESSIBLE
IF YOU'RE NOT IN A PRISON THAT
HAS. OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
CONNECTED TO IT YOU'RE TOTALLY
SCREWED AND YOUR STATE
PROPERTY. AND YOU'RE IN TROUBLE
IF YOU DON'T HAVE SUNSCREEN.
AND I THINK THAT A DISSERVICE
IT'S DONE IS WOMEN PEOPLE WHO
ARE INCARCERATED I DON'T THINK
THAT'S NECESSARILY A WOMEN'S
ISSUE COME BACK INTO THE WORLD
HAVING SPENT WHATEVER AMOUNT OF
TIME THEY HAD. EITHER DOING
EVERY SINGLE THING THEY CAN TO
HANG ON TO THEIR SANITY
MISERABLE FOR THE DURATION OF
THEIR TIME BECAUSE THEY REFUSE
TO BUY INTO THE IDEA THAT THEY
HAVE. NO HUMANITY OR COMING OUT
BEING TRAINED TO BELIEVE THAT
THERE STATE PROPERTY. AND. THAT
IN CAPS LEADS IT FOR ME THAT'S
WHERE THE SYSTEM IS FAILING
PEOPLE. I'M SOMEONE WHO MADE A
TERRIBLE DECISION I AM NOT THE
PROPERTY OF AN ORGANIZATION
THAT DOESN'T REMEMBER MY NAME
MAKES MONEY OFF OF ME BEING
INCARCERATED. GETS MAD AT ME
FOR GETTING A SUNBURN. SO THANK
YOU FOR SAYING THAT. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU SO WHY DON'T WE GIVE
A COLLECTIVE ROUND OF APPLAUSE
.
THANK YOU JUST A NOTE THAT WAS
NOT FOR ME THAT WAS FOR ALL OF
YOU. SO NOW WE ARE GOING TO
TRANSITION INTO OUR SECOND
PANEL AND WHILE WE MAKE THE
TRANSITION I JUST WANT TO RECAP
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT. I TOOK
NOTES SñNG. THAT ARE.
WARRIORS SISTERS SAID THAT 95%
OF THOSE WOMEN INCARCERATED OUR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURVIVORS
THAT ARE FURTHER TRAUMATIZED IN
PRESENT. THAT WE THINK THIS
TREATMENT IS NORMALIZED. THAT
THEY THINK THEY'RE BETTER THAN
US. THAT WE DIDN'T HAVE ANY
TOOLS. ONE OF OUR WOMEN SAID I
NEVER HAD A CHANCE. AND
ULTIMATELY I THINK ONE OF. A
FINAL COMMENT IS WE WANT YOU
HOME WOMEN WE WANT YOU HOME. SO
WITH THAT WE ARE GOING TO
TRANSITION INTO OUR SECOND
PANEL. AND THIS PANEL IS
COMPRISED OF PROFESSIONALS IN
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
AND WE HAVE A NUMBER OF FOLKS
WE HAVE PROSECUTORS WE HAVE
FOLKS THAT WORK IN THE JUDICIAL
SYSTEM. AND SO I TO I'M GONNA
LET. YOU ALL GETS IT WOULD WITH
EVERYONE'S HERE'S WE DON'T HAVE
TO DO THAT AM I WILL ALSO ASK
YOU ALL SOME QUESTIONS TO T.
YOU UP AND PLEASE FEEL FREE TO.
RESPOND TO THE QUESTIONS THAT I
ASK YOU CAN CERTAINLY FEEL FREE
TO GO WITH YOUR OWN FLOW WITH
WHAT YOU DECIDED THAT YOU WERE
GOING TO TALK ABOUT. AND YOU
SHOULD ALSO FEEL FREE TO
RESPOND TO WHAT YOU HEARD FROM
THE FIRST PANEL BECAUSE THIS IS
IT IS A CONVERSATION IT IS
ABOUT COALITION BUILDING BUT
ULTIMATELY IS THAT ABOUT. IT IS
ABOUT GAINING THE DATA THAT WE
NEED TO BE MORE EFFECTIVE IN
THE WORK THAT WE'RE DOING IS
LEGISLATORS TO FIX THE SYSTEM
AND I ACTUALLY BELIEVE THAT THE.
AS HARD AS THIS MAY BE TO HEAR
I BELIEVE THAT THE SYSTEM. IS
WORKING JUST FINE IT'S WORKING
AS IT WAS INTENDED TO DO. WHICH
IS TO INCARCERATE OVER PUNISH
OVER PENALIZE AND KILL PEOPLE
IN AND A WHOLE DIFFERENT WAY IN
A IN A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT WAYS
AND ULTIMATELY IT'S ABOUT THE
D. HUMINT HUMANIZATION. AND SO
IT'S DOING WHAT IT WAS DESIGNED
TO DO AND WE HAVE TO STOP THAT
WE HAVE TO DISMANTLE THAT. SO
QUESTIONS TO CONSIDER. I'M IN
WHAT WAYS DO YOU FEEL THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM NEEDS
TO BE REFORMED PARTICULARLY IN
REGARD TO SENTENCING. WHAT
BARRIERS ARE OBSTACLES HAVE YOU
ALL FACED TRYING TO IMPLEMENT
ANY REFORMS. WAS THERE A
TURNING POINT IN YOUR CAREER
WHEN YOU REALIZE THAT YOUR
PROFESSIONAL SKILLS COULD BE
USED AS A TOOL TO IMPLEMENT
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM. DO YOU
HAVE FAMILY MEMBERS OR FRIENDS
OR LOVED ONES WHO ALSO BEEN
TOUCHED BY THE PENAL SYSTEM.
AND I'M DO YOU VIEW THE
PRACTICE OF LAW THROUGH A
SOCIAL REFORM LANDS OR WHAT
LANDS DO YOU. VIEW THE PRACTICE
OF LAW SO ONCE AGAIN FEEL FREE
TO ENGAGE IN ANY OF THESE
QUESTIONS OR TO NOTS BUT
SOMETIMES WE LIKE CHECKERS AND
SO I WILL ONCE AGAIN START FROM
MY LEFT AND MOVED TO MY RIGHT.
AND PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
INTRODUCE AYE YOU WILL PRODUCE
YOURSELF TO THE AUDIENCE
BECAUSE ALL OF THIS IS BEING
RECORDED AND LIVE STREAMED
ACTUALLY I'M AND WE ALSO HAVE A
TWITTER FEED GOING. HI MY NAME
IS KEVIN HASSETT I AM A DEPUTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY I WORK IN LA
COUNTY. I'VE BEEN A DEPUTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY FOR TWENTY
FIVE YEARS. I'VE BEEN INVOLVED
IN AN ALTERNATIVE SENTENCING
COURT DOWNTOWN FOR THE PAST TEN
YEARS. BUT BY NUMBERS WISE I'VE
ACTUALLY BEEN INVOLVED IN
ALTERNATIVE SENTENCING ON
BECAUSE I DID IN COMPTON BEFORE
I CAME DOWNTOWN FOR MORE THAN
HALF MY CAREER. SO I AM SOMEONE
WHO COMPLETELY UNDERSTANDS THAT
A CASE IS NOT ABOUT THE PAPER
OR THE THINGS WRITTEN ON IT
IT'S ABOUT THE PERSON. BECAUSE
I HAVE THE PLEASURE OF MEETING
WOMEN AND MEN WHO HAVE CHOSEN
THROUGH THEIR ATTORNEY TO COME
TO THE ALTERNATIVE SENTENCING
COURT'S DOWNTOWN. SO I WOULD
LIKE TO EXPLAIN WHAT MY OFFICE
IS DONE TO TRY TO STEERED
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE BEEN
CHARGED WITH FELONIES. TO THE
ALTERNATIVE SENTENCING COURT'S
JACKIE LACEY HAS BEEN VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF ALTERNATIVE
SENTENCING COURTS AND THE
TREATMENT COURTS. IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN SHE WAS A PART
OF THE COMMITTEE THAT STARTED
OF THE WOMEN'S REENTRY COURT
AND ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER WHO WAS PART OF THAT
COMMITTEE IS HERE TODAY. IN
SUPPORT OF US AND THAT IS A
PROGRAM FOR FEMALE DEFENDANTS
SO I'M GOING TO TALK ABOUT THE
PROGRAMS THAT I AM INVOLVED IN
IF I COULD GIVE YOU A BRIEF
SUMMARY SO YOU UNDERSTAND WHAT
WE'VE ALREADY. AND MAYBE USE
THAT AS A STEPPING STONE TO GET
SOME DIALOGUE GULPING IN MAYBE.
TWEET AND I THINK. THE MAIN TWO
THINGS OUT OF THE WAY IS THE
MAIN TWO BARRIERS ARE MONEY.
AND TREATMENT AND THERE NEEDS
TO BE MORE OF BOTH. SO WITH
THAT SAID. ALTERNATIVE
SENTENCING COURTS ARE DESIGNED
FOR FELONIES LIKE I INDICATE
ITSELF THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES AT A DOWNTOWN A WE HAVE
A CITY ATTORNEY SO I DON'T HAVE
THE MISDEMEANORS BUT I DO HAVE
THE FELONIES SO USUALLY
INDIVIDUALS ARE CHARGED WITH. A
VERY SERIOUS CRIMES ARE CHEAP
THEY'RE FACING PRISON TIME
THEY'RE FACING JAIL TIME. SO I
AM INVOLVED IN SIX ALTERNATES
SENSING COURTS ONE OF THEM'S
CALLED THE SENTENCE DEFENDER
DRUG COURT IT'S THE MOST
SERIOUS PROGRAM THAT WE HAVE
IT'S DESIGNED FOR DRUG ADDICTS
AND IT DOES INVOLVE AN
INDIVIDUAL STARTING THEIR
TREATMENT IN JAIL. IT'S IN THE
TREATMENT POD AND IT'S
IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT REALLY
FOCUSES THE INDIVIDUAL ON
TREATMENT. AND THESE
INDIVIDUALS WOULD BE FACING
PRESENT OUR STATE OR JAIL TIME
ANYWAY. AFTER THAT THE RELEASED
INTO RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT AND
THEN THEY GO TO OUTPATIENT AND
THEN THEY GO TO AFTER CARE.
THEY ARE PLACED ON FIVE YEARS
OF PROBATION. AFTER THEY'VE
COMPLETED THEIR PROBATIONARY
TERM ABOUT HALFWAY THROUGH IF
THEY'VE DONE WELL. THEY LIED TO
THE COURT AND THE COURT
TYPICALLY GRANTS AND EXPAND
BENT AND THIS IS A DISMISSAL OR
THEY'RE ALLOWED TO WITHDRAW
THEIR PLEA. UNDER PENAL CODE
SECTION TWELVE OF THREE POINT
FOUR AND IF THE CHARGES WHAT WE
CALL THE WALL THERE WHICH MEANS
IT'S BETWEEN A FELONY AND
MISDEMEANOR THE JUDGE WILL
REDUCE AT SEVENTEEN BE. BUT
THESE ARE ALL POST CONVICTION
SENTENCING. SO THE NEXT PROGRAM
THAT WE RENDON MY COURT ROOM IS
ALSO THE CO OCCURRING DISORDERS
COURT IT IS FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE MENTALLY ILL AND ALSO HAVE
A SUBSTANCE ABUSE PROBLEM. AND
THOSE INDIVIDUALS DON'T START
OFF THEIR TREATMENT IN JAIL MAY
START OFF THEIR TREATMENT IN
ACTON ANTELOPE VALLEY
REHABILITATION CENTER FOR THREE
MONTHS A LOT OF THE INDIVIDUALS
WE DON'T ARE HOMELESS. SO IT
TAKES THEM OUT OF THEIR
ENVIRONMENT PUTS THEM AWAY AND
THEY CAN WALK AWAY IT IS NOT A
LOCKDOWN FACILITY BUT IT'S
DIFFICULT TO WALK AWAY SO THEY
MOST OF THEM ARE MOTIVATED TO
STAY THERE. THEY COME BACK
DOWNTOWN AND GO TO OUTPATIENT
AND SOBER LIVING. THE SAME
THING THEY COMPLETE THE PROGRAM
AFTER ONE YEAR APPROXIMATELY
THEY ARE POST CONVICTION POST
SENTENCING THEY GET THEIR
CHARGE REDUCED AND THEIR CASE
DISMISSED. BY THE NEXT ONE THAT
WE DO IS WHEN IT WAS RE ENTRY
COURT MEN'S REENTRY COURT IS
DIFFERENT THAN THE OTHER TWO
QUARTS IT WAS DESIGNED TO DEAL
WITH WOMEN'S ISSUES. SO APT
THAT FACILITY IT'S PROTOTYPES
IT'S IN POMONA THEY HAVE MORE
THAN JUST DRUG COUNSELORS WHICH
I THINK IS VERY IMPORTANT. THEY
HAVE THERAPISTS FOR THE
INDIVIDUALS THEY HAVE THEY
ALLOW CHILDREN UP TO THE AGE OF
ELEVEN THROUGH WOMEN CAN BRING
THEIR OWN CHILDREN THEY DO
TREATMENT WITH THEIR CHILD AND-
THEY TREAT THEIR CHILDREN ALONG
WITH THE MOTHERS. THEY HAVE A
PSYCHOLOGIST WHO CAN COME IN
AND DISTRIBUTE OCCASION. THEY
DEAL WITH TRAUMA THAT'S
BASICALLY WHAT THE PROGRAM IS
DESIGNED FOR WAS TO ASSIST
WOMEN WHO HAVE SUFFERED FROM
TRAUMA WHO HAVE SUFFERED FROM
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. WHO ARE
VICTIMS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING SO
I THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT THAT
THAT PROGRAM IS ALL
ENCOMPASSING THEY ALSO ALLOW
WOMEN WHO HAVE MEDICAL PROBLEMS
TO GO TO THAT TREATMENT PROGRAM.
SO THE GREATEST PART ABOUT THAT
PROGRAM WAS IT INITIALLY WHEN
IT WAS STARTED IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN THE PROGRAM WAS
APPROXIMATELY FIFTY PEOPLE AND
IT WAS DESIGNED AS A PILOT
PROGRAM THAT WAS FUNDED BY A
GRANT. NGUYEN DRUG MEDI CAL
CAME INTO PLAY WITH NOW BEEN
ABLE TO EXPAND THAT PROGRAM AND
WE HAVE ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY WOMEN IN THAT PROGRAM
NOW. SO IT STARTED OFF AT FIFTY
AND WERE A MUCH HIGHER NUMBER.
AND I THINK YOU KNOW AGAIN THE
PROBLEMS ARE THE NUMBERS AND
THE MONEY IS AN ISSUE SO I'M
ONE INDIVIDUAL I'M THE DA AND
THE COURT I GO TO COURT FIVE
DAYS A WEEK. THERE'S ONE OF ME
AND THERE'S ABOUT FIVE DEFENSE
ATTORNEYS THAT I WORK WITH. AND
SO I THINK ONE ISSUE WOULD BE A
NUMBERS GAME IF YOU WANT TO UP
THE NUMBERS INDIVIDUALS COMING.
YOU WOULD HAVE TO INCREASE THE
COURTS ASSIGNED OR THERE'D HAVE
TO BE PERHAPS A CHANGE IN
CULTURE. YOU KNOW OF I WAS
VIEWED AS AT IT'S VIEWED AS A
NON TRIAL ASSIGNMENT AND MISS
LACEY WAS VERY SUPPORTIVE OF ME
AND I WAS PROMOTED IN MY
ASSIGNMENT. BUT A LOT OF THE
DA'S DON'T VIEW THIS IS A VERY.
GOOD ASSIGNMENT AND SO THE
CULTURE HAS TO CHANGE I THINK
THE CULTURE IS CHANGING NOW
THROUGH THESE. THINGS AND
TALKING ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON
AND HOW IMPORTANT THESE ARE BUT
I WAS KINDA LOOKED DOWN ON IN
THE DA'S OFFICE SO. I'VE HELD
MY HEAD UP HIGH AND I KNOW THE
GOOD JOB THAT I DO EVERY DAY
AND THE PEOPLE'S LIVES THAT I
CHANGE AND THAT'S IMPORTANT HE-
VETERANS CORD IS ANOTHER
PROGRAM I'M GETTING TIMED OUT.
PROGRAM WE WON IN THAT IS ALSO
FOR WOMEN THERE'S LESS COMMON
IN THAT PROGRAM. AND OUT OF THE
PHOENIX. AS IN OTHER PROGRAMS
BROWN BALL DÂN AND N. O. D. R.
I DON'T DO DR BUT THAT'S
ANOTHER PROBLEM SO. JUST OFFICE
OF DIVERSION OF RE ENTRY.
SOMEONE TO TALK ABOUT IT. SO I.
INJUSTICES THAT THEY FEEL THAT
THEY HAVE SUFFERED AND I HOPE
THAT HELPS. SO BEFORE BY
DEGREES SPEAKS I WANTED TO SAY
TWO THINGS I ASKED IF YOU COULD
SAY WHAT DR IS BECAUSE WE ARE
LIVE STREAMING AND NOT EVERYONE
WILL KNOW THE ACT. THAT IT'S
JUST A GOOD REMINDER AND THEN
ALSO JUST WANTED TO LET
EVERYONE KNOW THAT THERE WILL
BE PUBLIC COMMENT AFTER THIS
PANEL IN ALL OF YOUR STATEMENTS
WILL BE RECORDED AND PUT IN THE
FILE SO I DIDN'T WANT FOLKS TO
FEEL LIKE WE'RE NOT GOING TO
HEAR FROM YOU IN THE AUDIENCE.
I'M GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS
BOBBY GRACE I AM ALSO A DEPUTY
DESCRIPTOR ANY. WITH LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AND I'VE BEEN.
IN THE OFFICE. LONGER THAN CAME
I'VE BEEN THAT. AND THE OFFICE
EVEN LIKE IT WHILE. THIRTY ONE
YEARS. SO I CAN TALK ABOUT. THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM FORM
I'M MORE. OVERALL VIEW. I DO
FEEL A LITTLE TREPIDATION
BECAUSE I'M LIKE THE ONLY MAN
HERE TALKING ABOUT WOMEN
INCARCERATIONS THAT. SO RIGHT
NOW I OUR OF OUR OFFICES
WRONGFUL CONVICTION SO.
INDIVIDUALS WHO FEEL THAT THEY
ARE FACTUALLY INNOCENT THEY CAN
MAKE A CLAIM WITH OUR
PARTICULAR UNIT AND ON. AND WE
WILL IF IT HAS MERIT WILL DO AN
INVESTIGATION. AND IF WE GET
THE GO AHEAD AND IT WILL GO TO
A JUDGE AND ASK A JUDGE TO
VACATE THE CONVICTIONS SO THAT.
IS PART OF A LARGER NARRATIVE
THAT YOU GUYS HAVE BEEN HEARING
ABOUT. A LARGE PART BECAUSE OF
THE CALIFORNIA. LEGISLATURE AND
SO YOU SHOULD GIVE THIS
ASSEMBLY PERSON AND YOU KNOW
ALL OF HER COLLEAGUES IN A
STATE GOVERNMENT HAVE LED THE
CHARGE FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM HERE IN CALIFORNIA IS
KIM SAID EVERYBODY'S NOT WITHIN
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM ON
THE PROSECUTION SIDE IS NOT ON
BOARD WITH THIS YOU SHOULD KNOW
THAT. BUT WHERE THE MONEY GOES
WHERE MONEY GOES FORCES CHANGE
AND SO A LOT OF THE MONEY THAT
HAS BEEN COMING INTO THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM FROM
THE STATE. AND ALSO FROM
LOCALLY FROM THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS HAS GONE TO THE
TYPES OF PROGRAMS THAT KIM IS
TALKING ABOUT ON A DAY TO DAY
BASIS AND THAT IS HAVING
MONUMENTAL CHANGE WITHIN THE
CROWDS AS A SYSTEM I CAN TELL
YOU TODAY. THAT. DAD LIVES ARE
BEING CHANGED ON A DAILY BASIS
BECAUSE- OF THE CHANGES THAT
ARE GOING ON WITHIN THE SYSTEM.
BUT ALSO TO TALK ABOUT IT FROM
THIS BROAD VIEW. SO THAT YOU
CAN UNDERSTAND WHAT HAPPENED TO
SOME OF THE WOMEN WHO GAVE
TESTIMONY TODAY. SO CALIFORNIA
WAS ONE OF THE FIRST STATES
THAT INSTITUTION DID THE
FEDERAL OF QUIBBLING OF
MANDATORY MINUTES MINIMUM.
MANDATORY SENTENCING. WHERE WE
INSTITUTED. SENTENCING
ENHANCEMENT SO WHERE IF YOU
WERE CONVICTED OF CERTAIN TYPES
OF CRIMES. AND YOU WERE CHARGED
WITH AN ENHANCEMENT IT ADDED
TIME AND THEN ALL OF YOU KNOW
ABOUT THREE STRIKES. IN SO ALL
OF THAT JUST BECAME CONASON
ARMY WITH IN CALIFORNIA WHERE
PEOPLE WERE WHO WERE. CONVICTED
OF VIOLENT CRIMES. STARTED
DOING IN ORDER IN AN AMOUNT OF
TIME. IN ADDITION TO WHATEVER
THIS SUBSTANTIVE CRIME THEY
HAVE BECAUSE OF THESE
ENHANCEMENTS AND SO THAT'S WHAT
YOU SEE HAPPENING WITH SOME OF
THE WOMEN WERE TALK ABOUT I WAS
DOUBLE CHARGED OR I THIS IN
HERE I GOT THAT'S ENHANCEMENT
THAT'S HOW THEY WERE GETTING
THE AT THE TYPE OF TIME THAT
THEY WERE GETTING. NOW THERE'S
BEEN A SIGNIFICANT CHANGE WITH
IN THAT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WHERE JUDGES ARE GETTING.
DISCRETION AS TO WHETHER OR NOT
THEY HAVE TO IMPOSE THE
SENTENCING HAMMOND THAT'S A
MAJOR SEA CHANGE IN CALIFORNIA.
ALSO THE THROUGH THE REFORM
EFFORTS AT THE STATE LEVEL NOW
STATE COURTS CAN GO BACK AND
TAKE A LOOK AT INDIVIDUALS HAVE
BEEN CONVICTED OF VIOLENT
CRIMES. AND DETERMINE WHETHER
THEY QUALIFY FOR RE SENTENCING.
SOME OF THAT IS DUE TO. BILL US
US SENATE BILL FOURTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN WHICH IS. OUR PENAL CODE
PILOTS IS WHAT YOU COM I KNOW
IT'S FELONY MURDER. THAT'S BEEN
A BIG CHANGE WITHIN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. PEOPLE
BEING ABLE TO COME BACK FOR
THAT AND ALSO. HAVE BEEN
CONVICTED OF A VIOLENT CRIMES
CAN COME BACK AND ASK FOR RE
SENTENCING FOR ISSUES LIKE. THE
FACT THAT THEY WERE BEING
TRAFFICKED. IN HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND OR THEY WERE
THE VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND THE PERSON THAT
THEY KILLED WAS A PERPETRATOR
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ON THEM.
SO THAT'S BEEN A BIG CHANGE IN
AND THAT GOES TO RIGHT TO THE
HEART OF WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT TODAY BECAUSE A LOT OF
WOMEN THAT AS YOU HEARD THAT
COME THROUGH THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM FOR VIOLENT
CRIMES. UNFORTUNATELY A LOT OF
TIMES A DAY BEEN SEXUALLY
TRAFFICKED. AND OR THEY WERE
THE VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND THE CRIME THAT THE
PERPETRATOR WAS AGAINST THE PER
PERSON WHO PERPETRATED CRIME
AGAINST THEM. I THINK IN THE
LONG RUN. WHAT WE SHOULD BE
TALKING ABOUT IN A AND THE
LEGISLATURE IS TALKING ABOUT IT
BUT IT'S A DIFFICULT PROBLEM
IS. THE BIG ISSUE OUT THERE IS
BE ALL REFORM. AND IT'S A VERY
DIFFICULT ISSUE WE HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET OUR ARMS
AROUND IT. BECAUSE THERE'S A
THERE'S A LOT OF ISSUES
INVOLVED WE WANT THE COMMUNITY
BE TO BE SAFE. BUT WE WANT
INDIVIDUALS TO HAVE OPPORTUNITY
TO GET OUT AND TO FIGHT THEIR
CASE. ON A FAIR BASIS AND SO WE
EVERYBODY WITHIN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM HAS TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO GET THEIR ARMS
AROUND IT AND HAVE IN IT TO BE
DONE IN A FAIR. MANNER WHETHER
IT'S SOME FORM OF MONEY BUILT
WHETHER IT'S A NO BAIL. MANY
PEOPLE ARE CONCERNED THAT IF
YOU HAVE NO NO MONEY BAIL. THAT
JUDGES WILL JUST DEFAULT TO
KEEPING EVERYBODY IN BECAUSE
THAT THAT'S GOING TO BE THE
SAFEST THING TO DO. SO THE
LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO SERIOUSLY
CONSIDER ALL THE RAMIFICATIONS.
OF BAIL REFORM AND TRY TO MAKE
SURE THAT WHEN WE DO THIS WE
DON'T DO IT PIECEMEAL THAT WE
DO IT WITH A GREAT STUDY AND
THAT WE DO IT RIGHT. SO THAT
PEOPLE ARE FAIRLY TREATED AND
THAT'S ONE THING I WANT TO SAY
THE LAST THING I WANT TO SAY IS
THAT IN TERMS OF THIS WHOLE
AREA OF THE WOMEN
INCARCERATION. KIM ALLUDED TO
THIS BUT WE NEED. IN THAT
WITHIN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM WE NEED THE MONEY. TO
IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAMS THAT
WERE MANDATED BY THE REFORMS
THAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT SO.
IF YOU WANT SOMEBODY TO BE ABLE
TO GET OUT. TO FIGHT THEIR
CRIME THEY NEED TO HAVE TO
PLACE TO GO TO IF YOU'RE GOING
TO DIVERT SOMEBODY BECAUSE THEY
HAVE A MENTAL ILLNESS OR
BECAUSE THEY'RE TRYING TO DEAL
WITH THE DRUG ADDITION. THEY
NEED TO HAVE A PLACE TO GO TO
WHERE THEY THEY CAN GET
TREATMENT. AND THAT THEY'RE NOT
GOING BACK OUT ON THE STREET
AND COMMITTING A CRIME BECAUSE
OF THE MENTAL ILLNESS THAT
THEY'RE FACING OR BECAUSE THAT
THE DEMONS THAT THEY'RE FACING
WITH RESPECT TO ADDICTION. AND
THAT'S PROBABLY THE BIGGEST
THING THAT WE TALK ABOUT WITHIN
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. IS
THAT THERE HAS TO BE. MONEY
ATTACH ANYTIME A BILL. IS
PASSED WHERE WERE MANDATING
REFORM THERE NEEDS TO BE MONEY
ATTACHED TO THAT SO THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT. THE GOOD
WORK THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO.
BUT I WANT TO SAY THAT THIS IS
TREMENDOUS I THINK THIS IS A
GREAT THING. THE OTHER THING I
WILL SAY IS THAT. THE LAST
THING ON A SAY IS THAT
STATISTICS. ARE SO IMPORTANT
WITH HOW WE GO ABOUT DOING WHAT
WE DO WITH IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. AND I SEE ISAAC
IS IN THE BACK OF THE ROOM.
HE'S BEEN A BIG PROPONENT OF
THIS AND I KNOW A LOT OF THE
CHAINS THAT'S BEEN HAPPENING.
LOCALLY HERE HAS BEEN DRIVEN
BY. THE MONEY THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS PUT UP FOR IT.
A DATA DRIVEN WORK. AND THAT'S
GOT TO CONTINUE PARTICULARLY IN
THIS SPACE BECAUSE OF THE MORE
DATA THAT WE HAVE AS TO WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH THE WOMEN. IN
PRISONS. WHY THEY MAY NOT BE
GETTING BAIL WHY THEY MAKE I
HAVE GOTTEN A PARTICULAR
SENTENCE THAT THEY GOT. THAT'S
GOING TO GIVE US THE AMMUNITION
TO BE ABLE TO MAKE. A DATA
DRIVEN REFORMS THAT ARE SO
NECESSARY WITH IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. AND I WANTED TO
SAY THAT. WHAT I HEARD THIS
AFTERNOON WAS JUST. HEART
WRENCHING. AND OPENED UP MY
EYES TO THE NEW KIM YOU SEE IT
EVERY DAY I'VE TRIED LIKE A
HUNDRED MURDER CASES. AND I YOU
KNOW I DON'T DEAL ON A DAY TO
DAY BASIS AS MMR CAREER I DON'T
DEAL WITH THIS PARTICULAR
ASPECT OF IT I'M DEALING WITH
IT WITH. OKAY THIS PERSON
COMMITTED MURDER I'M TRYING TO
GET THEM YOU KNOW. BUT I'VE
ALWAYS IN MY HEART ALWAYS
UNDERSTOOD THAT PEOPLE WERE
ALWAYS BETTER THAN THE WORST
DAY THAT THERE EVER HAD AND
THAT CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
NEEDS. TO LOOK AT EACH
INDIVIDUAL ON A EACH PERSON ON
AN INDIVIDUAL BASIS AND TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT. OF WHAT MAY HAVE
BROUGHT THEM TO WHERE THEY ARE
DOESN'T MEAN. THAT THEY DON'T
NEED TO BE PUNISHED IF THEY
ACTUALLY COMMITTED A CRIME.
WELL ALL EVERYBODY THAT COMES
WITHIN THE CRITICAL JUST AS
JUSTICE SYSTEM NEEDS TO BE
TREATED FAIRLY. IN ORDER. HELLO
GREAT HI GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE MY NAME IS VANESSA
MARTIN AND I AM THE DIRECTOR OF
THE RE ENTRY DIVISION AT THE
OFFICE OF DIVERSION REENTRY SO
I CAN TELL YOU ALL A LITTLE BIT
OFFICE OF DIVERSION REENTRY. I
JUST WANT TO START OUT BY
SAYING THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
AND A TO A TO MY FRIENDS HERE
BUT SHE WAS ADAM SOMEWHERE
WANDERING AROUND VERY I GOT AND
I REALLY WANT TO THINK THAT THE
PANEL THAT WAS HERE IN MY
FRIENDS WERE ON THE PANEL
INGRID AND SERRA. YOUR STORIES
ARE AMAZING INSPIRING AND HEART
WRENCHING AND THE FACT THAT
YOU. HAVE TAKEN ALL YOUR
EXPERIENCES AND ARE NOW HELPING
OTHERS WHO ARE IN SIMILAR
SITUATIONS YOURSELVES IS JUST
SOMETHING THAT I'M COMPLETELY
HUMBLED BY AND JUST GRATEFUL
THAT I CAN BE HERE IN SUPPORT
YOUR- AMAZING WORK THAT YOU DO.
SO THE OFFICE OF DIVERSION
REENTRY FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO
MIGHT NOT BE FAMILIAR WITH US
IS A BOARD OF SUPERVISOR
CREATED OFFICE HERE CREATED IN
TWO THOUSAND SEPTEMBER TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN. THREE FOUR
YEARS OLD NOW SO TODDLERS I
SUPPOSE AND WE WERE CREATED IN
AN EFFORT TO DIVERT PEOPLE WITH
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER OUT OF THE COUNTY
JAILS AND INTO COMMUNITY BASED
TREATMENT. I'M SORRY REALLY SEE
OURSELVES AS THE AS REALLY THE
CONDUIT BETWEEN PUBLIC SECTOR
BETWEEN COUNTY PART THE COUNTY
AGENCIES AND THE COMMUNITY
BECAUSE WE REALLY BELIEVE THAT
IN ORDER FOR PEOPLE TO IMPROVE
THEIR LIVES AND- BECOME
HEALTHIER. ON HUMAN BEINGS AND
REALLY YOU KNOW REFORM
THEMSELVES IN TRANSFORM
THEMSELVES ON THE WAY TO DO IT
IS THROUGH COMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIPS SO THAT'S THE OLD
THE MOST OF THE WORK THAT WE DO
IT WOULD BE OUR- AND WE HAVE A
LARGE BODY OF WORK ON THE
DIVERSION SIDE AND I AND LEAD.
OR RE ENTRY WORK WHICH IS A
MASSIVE MASSIVE BODY OF WORK AS
YOU CAN PROBABLY IMAGINE
THERE'S THIRTY THOUSAND BUDGET
RENTAL. FELONY IN AN ALLEY.
LOAN THAT'S. AND THEN. THERE'S
JUST FOUND OUT THE STATISTICS
TODAY FROM THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT SO THANKS TO THE
SHERIFF. THERE WERE. THEN ON
PEOPLE THERE'S TWO THOUSAND
WOMEN IT'S C. R. D. F. IN ANY
GIVEN DAY. SO YOU KNOW THESE.
ASTRONAUTS NUMBERS AND THE AND
UNFORTUNATELY FOR WOMEN SEEM TO
BE INCREASING. AND SO. YOU KNOW
WE REALLY SEE OUR CHARGES AS
DEVELOPING PROGRAMMING FOR
WOMEN WHEN THEY ARE COMING OUT
OF THE SYSTEM SO THAT COULD BE
ANYBODY WHO IS ON PROBATION
THAT'S ANYONE WHO'S COMING BACK
FROM STATE PRISON ON PAROLE. ON
THIS ANYBODY WHO'S BEEN IN THE
IN THE COMMUNITY MAYBE FOR
QUITE A BIT OF TIME IN MAY BE
UNDER NO SUPERVISION. BUT
ANYBODY WHO'S BEEN IMPACTED BY
THE SYSTEM. SO I'LL TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT SOME OF THE
INITIATIVES THAT WE'RE DOING.
AT DR ONE OF THE BIG
INITIATIVES JUST ON OUR OUR IN
OUR DIVERSION SIDE CONSERVE CAN
GIVE A SHOUT OUT. TO MY
COLLEAGUES THE DIVERSION CENTER
MEDICAL DIRECTOR DR CHRIS NO
CHIRLA. IS LEADING MANY EFFORTS
ARE BASED TO EFFORTS. I'M FOR
PEOPLE WHO HAD FROM SEVERE
MEANT. HEALTH ISSUES. INTO A
HIGH MENTAL HEALTH THE CUTIE
ISSUES. AND ONE OF THE ONE OF
THE INITIATIVES THIS WAS A
BOARD OF SUPERVISOR DIRECTIVE.
WAS TO DIVERT WOMEN WHO ARE
PREGNANT OUT OF THE JAILS. AND
INTO TREATMENT INTO PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING INTENSIVE
CASE MANAGEMENT. AND SERVICES
SO I JUST ACTUALLY GOT THE
STATS YOU ALSO AFTER EXCUSE ME
I WAS ASKED TO DO THIS IN THE
ELEVENTH HOUR. OUR DIRECTOR
JUDGES BUT NO THAT WAS SUPPOSED
TO BE HERE. SO I'M DOING MY
BEST. TO FILL AND A WOMAN SO I
FEEL LIKE IN A- THE. IN ANSWER
REALLY REALLY THRILLED ABOUT
THAT IN AGAIN I GOT INFORMATION
FROM COMMANDER ON. TARA ORDER
THIS MORNING AND SHE INFORMED
ME THAT. BUT THERE ARE
CURRENTLY THIRTY FIVE PREGNANT
WOMEN IN THE JAIL AND SHE SAID.
SHE SEEN THESE NUMBERS TO BE
MUCH MUCH HIGHER SO I THIRTY
FIVE IS A- HUGE IMPROVEMENT.
BUT AGAIN. STILL STILL ON A LOT
OF WORK TO BE DONE. SO I AM I
HAVE A LOT OF TALKING POINTS I
TRIED TO THROW TOGETHER PRETTY
QUICKLY. BUT I CAN ALSO JUST
ANSWER SOME OF THESE QUESTIONS.
THAT YOU RAISED. IN TERMS OF
WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO REFORM
THE SYSTEM. WHAT I PERSONALLY
SEE HOW I VIEW THIS WORK. I
VERY MUCH SEE IT THROUGH A
BASIC CIVIL RIGHTS. HUMAN
RIGHTS LANDS MY AGE. MY WORK
STARTED A VERY EARLY AGE
FIGHTING FOR A BROTHER WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY IN A
HOME FILLED WITH VIOLENCE. AND
I WASN'T. A FIGHTER BY NATURE
BUT I HAD TO FIGHT. FOR HIM AND
FIGHT FOR OTHERS AND SO WE AS
MANY OF YOU KNOW WHO MAYBE
FIGHTERS BY NATURE BUT HAS HAD
TO COME BY IT. UNDER YOUR
CIRCUMSTANCES YOUR THAT MUCH
MORE PASSIONATE ABOUT IT. AND
SO YOU KNOW THAT WORK HAS LED
ME. THROUGH MANY MANY SYSTEMS
FIGHTING FOR HIM IN FIGHTING
FOR PEOPLE IN SITUATIONS LIKE
HIM. AND ULTIMATELY STARTED MY
CAREER TWENTY YEARS AGO AND
CRIMINALS ARE. ACTUALLY BACK IN
NEW YORK CITY FIGHTING FOR
ALTERNATIVES TO INCARCERATION.
IN THE NINETIES UNDER THE
FILLER DRUG LAWS. AND SO THIS
IS BEEN A PASSION OF MINE FOR
MY ENTIRE LIFE. TWO MINUTES SO
I WILL SAY THAT I THINK WHAT WE
NEED TO. REFORM THE SYSTEM DOES
WORK WITH COMMUNITIES THE
COMMUNITIES NO THIS WORK I
THINK IT'S OUR JOB IN THE
PUBLIC SECTOR. TO SUPPORT THE
COMMUNITIES THAT DO THIS WORK
AND I WILL ALSO SUPPORT MY
OTHER PANELISTS AND- IN THE
DISCUSSION AND THE- THE
KNOWLEDGE MEANT THAT WE NEED
MORE DATA. SO IT AGAIN HUGE
HUGE STEP SHOUT OUT TO MILLION
DOLLAR HOODS AND THE ABILITY TO
GET THE DATA OUT OF THE SHARE
OF SYSTEM. AND DO SOMETHING
MEANINGFUL WITH IT AND ANALYZE
IT IN A WAY THAT'S USEFUL TO
ALL OF US. WHO ARE DOING THIS
WORK I THINK IT'S REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT TO HAVE THAT DATA HER
HANDS IN OUR FINGER TIPS.
BECAUSE WE NEED TO HAVE WE NEED
TO SET YOU KNOW HIGH STANDARDS
AND CONTINUE TO DO CONTINUES
CAN IMPROVE AND I THINK. SO A
TIME. COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS C. C. PUBLIC
SECTOR GOVERNMENT FUNDERS AS
COMING INTO AUDIT AND KIND OF
SLAP THEM ON THE WRIST AND WE
REALLY ATTEMPTED TO MAKE A VERY
DIFFERENT. APPROACH TO THIS AND
THAT IS ALL THROUGH CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT. AND THAT WE ARE
HERE TO SUPPORT YOU CANNOT
PENALIZE ON THE WORK THAT
YOU'RE DOING. AND SAID HELP
SUPPORT IT THROUGH THROUGH THE
ON THURSDAY AB. I THINK THE BIG
THING TOO IS. SOME OF THE
ANDREAS IS KIND OF BREAKING THE
SILOS. IN FIGURING OUT HOW TO
LEVERAGE RESOURCES RIGHT. HELLO
TO ALL THE HOUSE IN THE ROOM
RIGHT NOW. HEY WE ALL. HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO LEVERAGE
THOSE RESOURCES YOU KNOW IT'S
SQUEEZE OUT AS MUCH OF IT AS WE
POSSIBLY CAN. AND I THINK
BREAKING THE SILENCE IS REALLY
IMPORTANT I THINK DR IS. REALLY
UNIQUELY POSITIONED IN THAT WAY
BECAUSE WE ARE REPRESENTING THE
PEOPLE. PEOPLE POPULATION
RATHER THAN SERVICES MANY MANY
DEPARTMENTS ARE USUALLY
DESIGNED BASED ON FUNDING
STREAMS BASED ON SERVICES AND
THAT'S AND THAT'S ALL GREAT.
BUT WHAT WE FIND YOU KNOW WE
HAVE A WE ARE IS WE HAVE TO
FOCUS WE HAVE A FOCUS ON THE
POPULATION AND SERVING THE
UNIQUE NEEDS OF THIS
POPULATION. AND THAT TRANSCENDS
ALL OF THE COUNTY AGENCIES SO
WE HAVE TO. IT YOU KNOW WE HAVE
TO FIGURE OUT HOW BEST TO
LEVERAGE WHAT WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT EDUCATION MENTAL
HEALTH SUBSTANCE USE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. SO THAT'S THAT'S OUR
WORK IS REALLY TRYING TO BREAK
DOWN THOSE SILOS SILOS AND GET
TO THE HEART OF IT WHICH IS.
MEETING THE NEEDS OF THE
CLIENTS AND HEARING FROM THEM I
THINK. ANOTHER THING THAT'S A
CRITICALLY CRITICAL CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT AND THE WORK THAT WE
STARTED TO DO IT AGAIN SO
GRATEFUL. TO SERRA AND INGRID
AND OTHERS WHO WE WORK WITH
REALLY CLOSELY WE STARTED A-
AND I'M TRYING TO WATCH MY- SHE
WATCHED HER FOR THE TIME RIGHT.
ON AN INTENSIVE CASE MANAGEMENT
SERVICES PROGRAM AND REALLY
REALLY PROUD AND PLEASED TO SAY
THAT WE ARE NOW. AT ALMOST
THIRTY COMMUNITY WORKING WITH A
THIRTY COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS LA BY THE
END OF THE YEAR WILL HAVE A
HUNDRED. COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS THESE ARE ALL PEOPLE OF
LIVED EXPERIENCE OF
INCARCERATION. WHICH IS HUGE
AND THAT IS IT IS HUGE RIGHT I
CAN'T REALLY I DON'T HAVE ANY
BETTER KIND OF. WORD OR
ARTICULATION FOR THAT BUT IT'S
SO CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO HAVE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE HAD THOSE
EXPERIENCES I'LL BE THE
ADVOCATES IN THE MENTORS. IT'S
VERY MUCH A WHATEVER TAKES
APPROACH SO I MEAN SERICA. FOR
DATE WILL BE ABOUT ALL THE WORK
THAT THEY DO WORKING WITH THESE
CLIENTS SO I THINK THAT IS THE
FACT THAT THE WORK NEEDS TO BE.
FORMED BODY CLIENTS BUT ALSO
DRIVEN DECLINE AND HAVING MORE.
PEOPLE EXPERIENCE ACTUALLY
DOING THIS WORK AT THE TABLE I
THINK IS VERY VERY IMPORTANT.
AND I SEE MY JOB IS JUST
HELPING TO. THAT BRING OUT OF
HUMILITY IN AS MUCH FOR. EIGHT
AND LONG HOURS SUPPORT WORK I
THINK THAT'S PRETTY MUCH WHAT.
I WANTED TO COVER. WHAT
HAPPENED AFTER PRESS. YEAH
WHICH AGAIN THANK YOU FIRST OF
ALL I WANTED SOARED OFF ALL
KNOW THAT THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
HAS APOLOGIZED BUT HEARING THE
STORIES OF ALL OF THOSE PUBLIC
DEFENDERS DOTS REPRESENT YOU
BROKE MY HEART. AND I APOLOGIZE
ON BEHALF OF ALL OF YOU WHO
FELT HARMED OR IGNORED OR NOT
HEARD OR NOT CARED ABOUT
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN AVOID
DEFENDER FOR THIRTY TWO YEARS
AND I KNEW WHEN I WENT TO LAW
SCHOOL WHAT MY GOAL WAS TO BE I
CHOSE MY LAW SCHOOL BECAUSE OF
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE CLINIC AND
I KNEW THAT I WANTED TO
REPRESENT TEENAGERS WHO ARE
CHARGED WITH CRIMES. AND THAT'S
WHY SPENT MOST OF MY LIFE
FIGHTING TO DO. I WAS OFFERED A
JOB IN A WALL STREET LAW FIRM
AND I TURNED IT DOWN IN FACT TO
DO THIS AND SO WHEN I FIRST
STARTED REPRESENTING CLIENTS.
THIRTY TWO YEARS AGO I GOT WHEN
YOU'RE ON YOUR BODY. THEY WOULD
TELL ME WELL I WANT YOU KNOW I
WANT A REAL LAWYER. AND I JUST
SORT OF THROW UP MY HANDS YOU
KNOW START. I AM A REAL LAWYER
AND- WE START WITH THAT
PREJUDICE AND IT'S REALLY HARD
TO OVERCOME. BUT I BELIEVE THAT.
MY JOB IS A SACRED MISSION AND
I TAKE IT. THAT WAY AND I FIND
I HAVE. IN EVERY SINGLE CLIENT
THAT I'VE EVER REPRESENTED. I
BELIEVE HAS. HOPEFULLY FELT
THAT WAY THAT I AM COMMITTED TO
THAT. AND THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE LIKE THAT BUT
UNFORTUNATELY. FOR A LOT OF
REASONS THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE LIKE THE ONES THAT YOU
TALKED ABOUT AS WELL SO. THAT'S
MY APOLOGIES. SO I. WANT TO SEE
THAT CAME TO THE ALTERNATE HOW
DEFENDER'S OFFICE ABOUT FIVE
YEARS AGO BECAUSE- AT THAT
POINT IN TIME WE HAD BEEN
FIGHTING A SYSTEM FOR ALMOST
TWENTY YEARS WHERE HALF OF THE
KIDS WHO WERE ARRESTED IN. LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WE'RE GIVEN A
PANEL ATTORNEY WHO WAS PAID
THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR A
CASE. AND THAT WAS IT. AND AS A
RESULT THEY WERE GETTING
BASICALLY NO REPRESENTATION. SO
I CAME TO ALTERNATE PUT
DEFENDERS OFFICE TRY TO HELP
THEM GET THE CONTRACT AND
ULTIMATELY. THE BOARD FINALLY
DID THAT THREE YEARS AGO AND I
JUST WANNA SEE WE NOW HAVE
TWENTY FIVE LAWYERS. MOST OF
THE LAWYERS 95% OF LAWYERS IN
MY UNIT. OUR EXPERIENCED FAMILY
LAWYERS WHO ARE THERE BECAUSE
THEY WANT TO BE OR THERE TO
STAY. WE HAVE CHANGE THINGS
AROUND SO MUCH THAT ABOUT. FOUR
YEARS AGO. KIDS WERE GOING TO
ADULT COURT KIDS WERE BEING
TRANSFERRED TO ADULT COURT
ABOUT. 75% OF THE ONES WHO WERE
FILED ON WE'RE GOING TO ADULT
COURT. MY OFFICE NOW HAS
CHANGED THAT OF ALL OF THE
CLIENTS THAT WE REPRESENTED.
80% OF THEM ARE STAYING IN
JUVENILE COURT SO WE ARE
CHANGING THE MISSION. THAT'S
THE GOOD NEWS IS A LOT OF GOOD
NEWS. THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT
JUVENILE CRIME AND DESPITE WHAT
PEOPLE THINK IN HERE GENERAL
CRIME IS DOWN. BY SEVENTY
PERCENT. ARE WE HAVE CLOSED
DOWN VIRTUALLY CLOSED DOWN MANY
OF THE JUVENILE PRISONS
WITHDRAWN FROM. TRUE WHAT TEN
THOUSAND KIDS IN JUVENILE
PRISON TWENTY YEARS AGO. TO
LESS THAN SEVEN HUNDRED AT THIS
POINT IN TIME. WE HAVE JUVENILE
HALLS AND CAMPS CLOSING. AND
WE'VE HAD AMAZING LEGISLATION
WE HAVE ALL OF THE THINGS
AROUND. JUVENILES WERE
SENTENCED TO LIFE WITHOUT
PAROLE NOW GETTING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PAROLE. WE
HAVE CHILDREN UNDER TWELVE NO
LONGER IN THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM MY GOD HOW LONG DID THAT
TAKE TO FIGURE OUT. WE NO
LONGER HAVE FOURTEEN AND
FIFTEEN YEAR OLDS. GOING TO
ADULT COURT SO THERE'S BEEN
SOME REALLY MAJOR CHANGES ON
THE STATE LEVEL. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER. I'M WHEN ALSO
ON THE LOCAL LEVEL WE'VE
ELIMINATED SOLITARY CONFINEMENT
FOR JUVENILES WE'RE IN THE
PROCESS THE LIVES OF
ELIMINATING PEPPER SPRAY. WE
ARE NOW STUDYING HOW TO REMOVE
PROBATION FROM THE OVERSIGHT OF
JUVENILES BECAUSE OF THE
FAILED. SYSTEM THAT WE'VE HAS
DEVELOPED AND WE ARE POSSIBLY
WRITTEN MOVING TOWARDS MORE
HARM REDUCTION MEDICAL MODEL
NOT ONLY FOR THE KIDS IN THE
LOCAL SYSTEM BUT ALSO. GOVERNOR
NEWSOME HAS ANNOUNCED THAT HE'S
PLANNING TO REMOVE DJJ FROM CDC
ARE INTO A POTENTIALLY DEVELOP
TO DEPART HEALTH SERVICES SO
ALL THAT IS GREAT NEWS. BUT
THEY'RE STILL BAD NEWS AND
BECAUSE WE'RE HERE TO TALK
ABOUT GIRLS AND WOMEN. THE BAD
NEWS IS THAT THE PROPORTION OF
GIRLS IN THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM HAS INCREASED. AT EVERY
STAGE OF THE PROCESS. I DON'T
MEAN THE NUMBER OF GIRLS IS AS
I'VE SAID THE CRIME LEVEL HAS
GONE DOWN BUT THE PROPORTION
HAS RISEN. AND THAT'S OVER ALL
STAGES THE PROCEEDINGS ARREST
DETENTION AND PROBATION. AND
THE OTHER BAD NEWS IS THAT THE
GENDER GAP IS TREMENDOUS IN THE
DETENTION OF GIRLS FOR REALLY
LOW LEVEL CRIMES YOU LOOK AT.
WHO'S DETAINED FOR LOW LEVEL
CRIMES THE PERCENTAGE IS MUCH
HIGHER FEMALE PERCENTAGE. WE
ALSO KNOW AND I THINK ANY. ONE
IN THIS ROOM KNOWS THAT. THE
REASON GIRLS AND UP IN THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM. 31% OF
THE STUDY FOR TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN REPORTED A PERSONAL
EXPRESSES SEXUAL VIOLENCE IN
THE HOME FORTY OVER 40% HAVE
BEEN FITTED PHYSICALLY ABUSED
84% HAVE FAMILY ABUSE THEY
REPORT SEXUAL ABUSE AT THE RATE
OF OVER FOUR AND A HALF TIMES
THAT OF BOYS COMING INTO THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM. AND
THAT TELLS US A LOT. ABOUT WHY
GIRLS ARE IN THE JUSTICE SYSTEM
AND ALSO ABOUT. WHAT WE NEED TO
DO AND HOW WE CAN ADDRESS THIS
TO ME IT MEANS THAT THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM IS NOT THE PLACE. TO
HEAL. ANYBODY BUT ESPECIALLY TO
HEAL TRAUMATIZED KIDS SO MY
NUMBER ONE SUGGESTION FOR
REFORM IS KEEP US OUT OF IT I
MEAN I LOVE MY JOB. WHAT WHAT
YOU KNOW I'M GONNA RETIRED A
COUPLE YEARS AND MIGHT YOU KNOW
KEEP US OUT OF IT BECAUSE WE
DON'T DO IT WELL IT'S NOT OUR
PURPOSE SO I AM REALLY HAPPY
ABOUT THE- EFFORTS THAT HAVE
BEEN MADE THE TREMENDOUS
EFFORTS HAVE BEEN MADE BY THE
OFFICE OF DIVERSION RE ENTRY.
AND I THINK WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
A LOT OF SUCCESS WITH THAT NOT
JUST BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING TO
SORT OF DIVERT IN NAME BUT
BECAUSE THEY'RE BACKING IT UP
WITH LISTENING TO THE RIGHT
PEOPLE ABOUT HOW THEY SHOULD DO
IT. I THINK ANOTHER SUGGESTION
THAT I HAVE AND I AND I THINK
APRIL STORY TOUCHED ME SO MUCH
BECAUSE- AS HORRIBLE AS IT IS.
IT IS SO TYPICAL. IT IS JUST
IT'S A. IT'S SOMETHING I HEAR
DAY IN AND DAY OUT ABOUT HOW.
THIS THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM IS
BROKEN. AND I GO THERE EVERY
TWO WEEKS AND I REPRESENT KIDS
WHO ARE DAHLE STATUS KIDS KIDS
WERE CROSSED OVER. AND I'M JUST.
I'M JUST BLOWN AWAY THAT PART
OF IT IS BECAUSE IT'S VERY
SECRET CONFIDENTIAL AND THE
PROCEEDINGS ARE CLOSE SOMETIMES
FOR VERY GOOD REASONS BUT- I'M
BLOWN AWAY AT AT OUR OUR- OUR
WILLINGNESS TO ALLOW THIS TO GO
ON I MEAN THE SYSTEM'S BROKEN.
THE TOURNEY'S HAVE HUNDREDS OF
CASES THEY- REALLY CAN'T DO
ANYTHING THEIR PARALYZED FROM
BEING ABLE TO DO ANYTHING. THE
THERE'S NO TRAUMA SCREENING IT
MANDATORY FOR KIDS IT SHOULD BE
FOR EVERY KID THE SHIP EVERY
KID SHOULD HAVE EDUCATIONAL
SCREENING YOU DON'T KNOW HOW
MANY KIDS COME TO THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM. AND THEY'VE
NEVER HAD NINETY P. THEY'VE
NEVER HAD ANY BE LOOK AT OUR
SCHOOL SYSTEM AND SEE WHAT WHAT
ARE THE PROBLEMS THAT THEY NEED
SO THEIR FALLING THROUGH THE
CRACKS IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM IN THEIR ENDING UP IN
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM. I
THINK THE THIRD. SUGGESTION I
HOUSES THAT IF YOU WITH WE DO
HAVE THEM KIDS IN THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM WE REALLY. NEED
TO RE HALL WHAT WE'RE DOING
BECAUSE WE HAVE VERY FEW
OPTIONS. YOU GO HOME OPERATION
GO TO CIVIL PLACEMENT WHICH IS
A GROUP HOME WHICH IS A
TERRIBLE IDEA. YOU CAN GO TO
CAMP YOU CAN GO TO PRISON.
THAT'S BASICALLY IT WE REALLY
DON'T HAVE THE TOOLS THAT WE
NEED. AND MORE YOU KNOW THAT
THERE'S MORE THAN ACCESS TO
SERVICES. WHICH IS A BIG THING.
I THINK THAT. WHAT WE NEED IS
THAT WHAT I SAID HARM REDUCTION
POSITIVE YOUTH DEVELOPMENT
MODEL I THINK THAT WE NEED TO
GIVE GIRLS YOUNG WOMEN SELF
ESTEEM. A SENSE OF EMPOWERMENT
AND INDEPENDENCE AND
UNFORTUNATELY OUR JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM IS BEING IS
GEARED TOWARDS SUBMISSION
OBEDIENCE AND TO A VERY
PATRIARCHAL. AT A STORE TATE OF
MODEL. SO THIS IS A SMALL
LITTLE CHANGES YOU KNOW LET'S
JUST. CAME THROUGH. THANK YOU
SO I WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU
FOR YOUR HONESTY AND FOR YOUR
COURAGE AND BOTH TALKING ABOUT
YOUR WORK AND THE EFFORTS THAT
YOU SEE AHEAD WE'RE GOING TO
NOW OPEN IT UP TO PUBLIC
COMMENT SO I WANT FOLKS TO KIND
OF. I GUESS LINE UP HERE WE GO.
AND WHILE WE DO THAT. I WANT TO
MAKE A COUPLE OF COMMENTS
MYSELF. WE HAVE BEEN MAKING
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE AT THE STATE
LEVEL BUT I HAVE TO TELL YOU
THAT THE BATTLE IS UP THE HILL
THERE ARE OVER A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY SENTENCE ENHANCEMENTS
THAT ARE STILL ON THE BOOKS AND
SO WHILE WE TALK ABOUT YOU KNOW
BILL REFORM THE BIGGEST ISSUE
IS SENTENCING REFORM. AND OUR
BIGGEST OPPOSITION ACTUALLY
COME FROM THAT THE D. A.'S AND
SO WE THERE'S ALSO WHEN I'M SO
GLAD THAT YOU MENTIONED THIS IN
YOUR COMMENTS IT'S AS MUCH
ABOUT MONEY AND RESOURCES AS IT
IS ABOUT CULTURE CHANGE BECAUSE
IT'S REALLY HARD FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO SAY I'M GOING TO
FUND THIS IF WE FEEL LIKE WE'RE
FUNDING A SYSTEM THAT WE ALL
KNOW TO BE BROKEN WITHOUT ANY
ASSURANCES THAT THERE'S GOING
TO BE SOME SORT OF CULTURAL
CHANGE IN THE SYSTEM. AND SO
HOW DO WE HOW DO WE DO THAT AND
YOU KNOW HOW DO WE ACCEPT AND
EMBRACE MORE JUDICIAL
DISCRETION WIN IT REVEALS
ITSELF IN SENTENCING
DISPARITIES YOU SEE AND SORROW
PEOPLE USE DESCRIPTIVE JUDGES
WILL USE THEIR DISCRETION YOU
KNOW FOR CERTAIN FOLKS AND NOT
FOR OTHERS AND I THINK THAT THE
BROCK TURNER CASE WAS A GREAT
EXAMPLE OF AN OUTRAGE. WITH A
JUDGE USING JUDICIAL DISCRETION
BUT IT SEEMS LIKE ALL IT WAS
USED FOR THIS WHITE MAN. AND
NOT IN ANY OTHER CASE THAT WE
HAVE SEEN IN THAT WAY AND SO
HOW DO WE REALLY HAVE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT RACE AND
CLASS AND GENDER IN THIS
SYSTEM. AND THEN THE FINAL
THING IS YOU KNOW I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT YOU BUT YOU KNOW FIVE
YEARS ON PROBATION A REALLY
LONG TIME. I MEAN I CAN HARDLY
GO TWO WEEKS ON A DIET WITHOUT
MAKING. IT SO DO YOU THINK
SOMEONE IS GOING TO GO IF YEARS
WITHOUT. YOU KNOW IT IT'S
BREAKING A VIOLATE IT'S A
VIOLATION OF ANY LAW OF ANY
LONG JAY WALKING J. WORKING.
AND SO WE HAVE TO KIND OF HAVE
REAL CONVERSATIONS ABOUT IF
THAT'S EVEN DESIGNED TO HAVE
PEOPLE REHABILITATE IF I'M
BEING WATCHED FOR FIVE YEARS.
THERE'S NO WAY ON GOD'S GREEN
EARTH I'M NOT GOING TO MAKE ANY
KIND OF MISTAKE ON ANY GIVEN
DAY AND SO WHAT ARE WE REALLY
TALKING ABOUT. BUT I APPRECIATE
THE FACT THAT ALL OF US ARE IN
THIS FIGHT TOGETHER AND WE'RE
COMING AT IT FROM DIFFERENT
ANGLES AND WE DO NEED TO
SUPPORTER DA'S OFFICES AND WE
NEED TO SUPPORT A PUBLIC
DEFENDERS BECAUSE SPENDING
SEVEN MINUTES ON AVERAGE WITH
THE CLIENT. IS NOT GOING TO GET
BACK LINE DUE PROCESS I DON'T
KNOW HOW YOU FIND TO PROCESS
AND SEVEN MINUTES. AND SO WE
HAVE TO HAVE A REAL
CONVERSATION ABOUT THAT. AND
WHO GETS A PUBLIC DEFENDER AND
WHO DOESN'T. SO WITH THAT I AM
GOING TO ALSO SAY THAT THIS IS
THE FIRST IN A SERIES OF
HEARINGS ON OUR SECOND ONE WILL
HAPPEN IN FEBRUARY AND- ALL IN
THAT HEARING WE WILL ACTUALLY
DELVE INTO THE EXPERIENCES. OF
WOMEN WHILE INCARCERATED SO WE
WILL BE TALKING ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENS IN PRISON AND IN JAIL
AND THE TRAUMAS IN THE
MISTREATMENT BECAUSE WE HAVE TO
FIX THIS PROBLEM FROM ALL SIDES.
SO WITH THAT I WANT TO OPEN IT
UP. PUBLIC COMMENT IF YOU HAVE
NINETY SECONDS THIS WILL BE
JUST LIKE A HEARING. WELL THIS
IS A HEARING SO PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME AND MY NAME IS THE
THAT READS AND UNFORTUNATELY MY
FAMILY MEMBER WAS ONE THAT DID
NOT GET A GOOD PUBLIC DEFENDER
HE IS SERVING HIS THIRTY
SEVENTH YEAR OF A TWO HUNDRED
AND FOUR YEAR SENTENCE NO PRIOR
CONVICTIONS. HE WAS EIGHTEEN AT
THE TIME SOCIAL FINALLY GET. A
CONSULTATION HEARING FOR YOUTH
PAROLE HEARING BUT WE HAVE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO GET ANY HELP AND
WE DID DO THE DA CONVICTION
REVIEW. IT WAS DENIED BECAUSE
THEY SAID THERE WAS NO NEW
EVIDENCE SO IS THERE SOMETHING
DIFFERENT THAT YOU'RE DOING
BECAUSE IF THERE IS ACTUAL
INNOCENCE AND YOU GUYS ARE JUST
DENYING IT BECAUSE YOU SAY WHAT
YOU HAVE TO HAVE NEW EVIDENCE.
THAT'S NOT A CASE REVIEW AND
THERE WERE SO MANY THINGS WRONG
WITH THAT CASE NO PRIOR
CONVICTIONS I MEAN IT IT'S A
KID THAT HAS BEEN IN PRISON FOR
THIRTY SEVEN YEAR. SO ARE YOU
AND WHAT WAS IT IN LA COUNTY
YES. AND WHEN WAS IT WHEN WAS
THE STATE NINE HI TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN WE WERE LIKE ONE OF THE
FIRST CASES TO APPLY FOR THE D.
HAVE CONVICTION REVIEW AND THE
CALIFORNIA INNOCENCE PROJECT
HAS BEEN TRYING TO GET
INFORMATION FROM YOUR OFFICE WE
HAVE MOTIONS. EVERYTHING IN
YOUR OFFICE IS JUST NOT. FIND
WITH A THE ORDERS I'LL GIVE YOU
MY CARD. BEFORE EVEN YOU CAN.
IF JUST TELL BY NOW RESUBMIT IT
AND I'LL I'LL TAKE A LOOK AT WE
APPRECIATE IT WOULD BE GREAT
FOR SOME OF THOSE BECAUSE-
THERE MAY BE SOME CONSTITUENT
CASE WORK THAT POPS UP. THAT WE
WOULD LOVE FOR OUR PANELISTS TO
STAYS SO THAT FOLKS CAN MAYBE
ASK SOME MORE PERSONAL
QUESTIONS AND GET. PHONE
NUMBERS ARE RESOURCES THAT YOU
ALL HAVE SO THAT PEOPLE ARE SO
EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS WHAT SHE'S
TALKING ABOUT IS WHEN PEOPLE
COME BEFORE US FOR. WRONGFUL
CONVICTION CLAIMS. ONE OF THE
STANDARD OR ONE OF THE CRITERIA
IS THAT YOU HAVE HAVE NEW
EVIDENCE THAT THE ORIGINAL JURY
DIDN'T HEAR. AND THE REASON WHY
WE HAVE THAT CRITERIA IS
BECAUSE FOR A JUDGE TO OVERTURN
A CONVICTION. THE LEGAL
STANDARD IS. IF THE REGIONAL
JURY KNEW WHAT THEY KNEW NOW
WOULD THEY HAVE REACHED A
DIFFERENT CONCLUSION AND SO
WE'VE GOT TO HAVE SOMETHING
NEW. TO GIVE THE JUDGE IN ORDER
TO CONVINCE THE JUDGE THAT.
PERHAPS THIS IS THE ORIGINAL
JURY IS WRONG BECAUSE. THE
LEGAL SYSTEM IS A LOW. TO
OVERTURN CONVICTIONS BECAUSE
THEY DON'T WANT TO SECOND GUESS
THE JUDGMENT OF JURY I AM WE
PROVIDED NEW EVIDENCE BUT IT
WAS STILL TONIGHT. AND HE SAID
IT WAS IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
CORRECT OKAY YEAH DEFINITELY
SEEN ME BEFORE. THANK YOU. HEY
WE MUST MAKE A MOTEL THANK YOU
ALL SO MUCH FOR COMING AND
PARTICIPATING I'M ALSO FORMERLY
INCARCERATED WOMAN AND SO MY
DUTY HERE TODAY IS TO IS TO
BRING IN THE SISTERS THAT ARE
STILL SITTING INSIDE BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT EVERYTHING ONE OF
US ARE HERE DOING THE WORK IS
DOING A FOR US TO BRING OUR
FOLKS HOME AND TO CONTINUE TO
TALK ABOUT THE CONDITIONS. THAT
ARE CURRENTLY HAPPENING
IMPRISONED SO REALLY WANTING TO
ADDRESS THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
YOU KNOW YOU KIND OF WENT
THROUGH THE LIST OF HOW WE GET
BROKEN OFF OF THESE BIG LONG
SENTENCES YOU KNOW SENTENCE
ENHANCEMENTS AND DOUBLE
SENTENCES AND ALL THIS AND A
NUMBER OF FOLKS HAVE ADDRESSED
THE TRAUMA THAT WE CONTINUE TO
EXPERIENCE IN PRISON YOU JUST
MENTIONED BROCK TURNER SO I
WANTED TO SPEAK UP AND ASK WHAT
YOUR THOUGHTS ARE ABOUT THE
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS IN CA
WCCW F. THAT ARE BEING
CONVICTED OF SEXUAL ASSAULTS.
BUT BEING CONVICTED OF SEX
WITHIN IN ME RATHER THAN RAPE
WALKING AWAY WITH TWO DAYS IN
JAIL AND TWO YEARS PROBATION I
WANT TO KNOW HOW THAT'S
HAPPENING IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN AND HOW IS THAT DAY
THE ONES WITH THE KEYS TO
OURSELVES AND THE WAS A CONTROL
WHETHER OR NOT WE PICK UP THE
PHONE AND TALK TO OUR CHILDREN.
OR VISIT OUR FAMILY AND OUR
SITTING ROOMS. THAT THEY THAT
THERE'S ANY SORT OF STRUCTURE
IN PLACE IN PRISON FOR
CONSENSUAL SEX. SO JUST
WONDERING IF YOU COULD SPEAK TO
THAT. ARE YOU GUYS I'M SORRY I
DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT THAT
I CAN'T SPEAK TO THAT IT SOUNDS
HORRIBLE BUT I'M SORRY I DON'T
HAVE KNOWLEDGE IS TO THAT.
SOMEONE WRITE MY STUFF IS
BEFORE YOU GO TO PRISON SO IT
SOUNDS HALL AWFUL BECAUSE
BECAUSE- AGAIN WE HAVE TO RELY
ON YOU LIKE THIS IS THE SYSTEM
WE HAVE. NONE OF US WANT TO
PUSH FOR. FURTHERING HER
SERRATION AND- PUSHING PEOPLE
INTO THE SYSTEM. AND THAT'S
WHAT WE HAVE TO RELY ON RIGHT
NOW AND WE HAVE TO TAKE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR OUR CRIMES
BUT CORRECTION OFFICERS ARE
WALKING AWAY. I THINK. I WILL
ANSWER THIS I APPRECIATE YOU. A
KNOWLEDGE IN THIS BECAUSE OFTEN
TIMES AND I HAVE DONE TOURS OF
PRISONS AND- NO ONE WANTS TO
TALK ABOUT IT RIGHT BUT THEN WE
HEAR THE STORIES WE HEAR HOW
PROGRAMS. ARE LEVERAGED RIGHT
HOW WOMEN ARE LEVERAGE IF THEY
WANTED TO A CERTAIN PROGRAM IN
AND HOW THAT CAN BE CUT SHORT
IF THEY'RE NOT DOING THINGS
THAT THEY- ARE BEING ASKED TO
DO THAT THEY PROBABLY WOULDN'T
BE ASKED TO DO IF THEY WERE NOT
INCARCERATED IN ORDER TO STAY
IN A PROGRAMMER GET ADDITIONAL
PRIVILEGES. THAT CON ASIAN IS
REALLY FOR THE FOLKS WHO ARE IN
CDC ARE IN THE CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS AND THAT'S ACTUALLY
GOING TO BE HAPPENING IN OUR
NEXT HEARING BECAUSE WE WANT TO
HAVE HONEST CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
THAT ABOUT TO TALK ABOUT THE
EXPERIENCES THAT WOMEN ARE
HAVING WHILE THEY ARE IN JAIL
AND WHILE THEY'RE IN PRISON
THIS HEARING IS REALLY ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENS BEFORE YOU EVEN
GET TO JAIL. WHAT OTHER
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT MAY BE LED
YOU TO BEING INCARCERATED
BECAUSE IF WE ARE GOING TO
DISMANTLE AND FIX THE SYSTEM WE
HAVE TO COME AT IT FROM
MULTIPLE SITES AND THE LEG OF
THIS THREE LIKE IT'S TOOL IS
THE ENTRY POINT THE SECOND LEG
IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU'RE
INSIDE HOW ARE WOMEN ARE WOMEN
A LET'S NOT ASSUME ARE WOMEN
FURTHER DE HUMANIZED RIGHT AND
WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE AND
THEN THE THIRD LEG OF THE STOOL
IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU COME
OUT WITH RE ENTRY HOW
SUCCESSFUL IS YOUR RE ENTRY
EXPERIENCE HOW ARE WE FAILING
YOU SO HOW ARE WE FAILING YOU.
TO FORCE YOU INTO A SYSTEM. OUR
WE FAILING YOU WHEN YOU'RE IN
THE SYSTEM. HOW ARE WE FAILING
WHEN YOU COME OUT OF THE SYSTEM
NOW I HAVE TO CHECK MY OWN BIAS
BECAUSE MAYBE WERE NOT FAILING
IN MANY INSTANCES BUT I YOU
KNOW I TO BEEN TRAUMATIZED AS
SOMEONE WHO HASN'T EVEN BEEN IN
THE SYSTEM BUT HAVE BEEN
TOUCHED BY SO MANY FOLKS WHO
HAVE BEEN TOUCHED BY IT. SO I'M
ACKNOWLEDGING MY BIAS BUT THIS
THIS PANEL IS REALLY ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENS. WHAT ARE THE STEPS
THAT. GET YOU INTO JAIL AND
INTO PRISON AND SO I WOULD ASK
THAT YOU TABLE THIS BECAUSE WE
NEED YOU HERE IN FEBRUARY WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT WHAT GOES ON SO
THAT YOU'RE ASKING THAT OF
FOLKS FROM CDC ARE IN YOU'RE
ASKING THAT OF CO. AND SO WE
PUT ALL THE CARDS ON THE TABLE
BECAUSE WE CERTAINLY CAN HEAL
IN THE DARK AGREE THINK ARE YOU
OKAY WITH THAT SO. I JUST WANT
TO SAY THAT THERE'S PARALLELS
TO LEADING INTO THE SYSTEM
WHETHER IT'S US OR WHETHER IT'S
THE CORRECTION OFFICERS AND SO
ACCOUNTABILITY AND DA
ACCOUNTABILITY IS SUCH A HUGE
PIECE OF THAT. THANK YOU. YEAH
I DON'T. ACTUALLY LIKE TO
FOLLOW UP ON. SORRY I MAKERS
QUESTION I UNDERSTAND THAT THIS
IS MAYBE CONVERSATION IT CAN BE
PICKED UP AGAIN IN FEBRUARY. I
LOOK FORWARD TO RETURNING AT
THAT POINT. I ALSO JUST WANTED
TO GIVE A HUGE HEARTFELT AND
DEEP THANK YOU AND
CONGRATULATIONS TO. ALL THE
WOMEN WHO APPEAR TODAY TO
SHARE. WE'VE HONORABLE STORIES
REALLY HEART WARMING STORIES
REALLY HOT. ENGINE STORIES AND
INDEED HEARTWARMING STORIES OF
RECOVERY AND STRENGTH. MY
QUESTIONS RECTITUDE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IN JUNE YOU VOTED TO
PASS SB ONE THIRTY TWO OUT OF
THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
THIS BILL PASSED BY THE SENATE
AND ASSEMBLY BUT CURRENTLY
INACTIVE. WHAT'S YOUR REQUIRES
THAT ANY INMATES WHO DECLARES A
TRANSGENDER IDENTITY BE HOUSED
IN A PRISON DESIGNATED FOR MEN
OR WOMEN BASED ON THAT
INDIVIDUAL'S PREFERENCE.
SECRETARY OF THE DEPARTMENT CAN
INTERVENE TO DENY THAT REQUEST
FOR SPECIFIC AND ARTICULABLE
REASON BUT THE REASON CANNOT BE
THE ABSENCE OF A GENDER
DYSPHORIA DIAGNOSIS OR ANY
MEDICAL STEPS TOWARDS
TRANSITION. ROLL HAS
DEMONSTRATED WHAT WE KNOW TO BE
TRUE ABOUT PEOPLE ASSIGNED
FEMALE AT BIRTH WHERE GENDER
NON CONFORMING BEING ESPECIALLY
VULNERABLE TO SEXUAL VIOLENCE.
NOT TO MENTION OTHER PEOPLE
BORN FEMALE WHO CONTINUE TO
IDENTIFIES WOMEN. SB ONE THIRTY
TWO MAKES NO MENTION OF THE
SAFETY AND PRIVACY RIGHTS OF
FEMALE INMATES NOR ANY SYSTEMIC
MEASURE TO PREVENT ABUSE OF
THIS POLICY. I SEXUALLY VIOLENT
MAN. THE BRITISH ASSOCIATION OF
GENDER IDENTITY SPECIALIST
TESTIFIED THAT IT IS NAIVE TO
SUGGEST THAT NO MAN WHO ARE NOT
GENUINELY TRANS GENDER. BUT HOW
VIOLENT MOTIVES WILL PRETEND TO
BE TRANSGENDER IN ORDER TO BE
TRANSFERRED INTO WOMEN'S
PRISONS AND IN FACT THIS HAS
BEEN THIS HAS HAPPENED MULTIPLE
TIMES. MY QUESTION TO YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WHY DID YOU
VOTE TO PASS THIS BILL WITHOUT
PROPER SAFEGUARDS TO ENSURE
THAT IT'S NOT ABUSED BY PEOPLE
WITH BAD INTENTIONS. SO
NORMALLY WHAT HAPPENS IN PUBLIC
COMMENT IN WE'VE STRAIGHT AWAY
SO WILL HAVE TO SELF CORRECT IS
THAT WE HAVE COMMON IN THE
PEOPLE ON THE DÍAS DO NOT.
RESPOND BECAUSE IT'S YOUR TIME
I WILL SAY THAT I HAD SOME
QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS BILL BUT
ULTIMATELY I VOTED FOR IT
BECAUSE CDC ARE HAS BEEN
ACTIVELY INVOLVED WITH THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL SENATOR
WIENER. AND MEMBERS OF THE
TRANSGENDER COMMUNITY ON THIS
ISSUE WE ARE SEEING A GROWING
NUMBER OF LGBTQ FOLKS WHO ARE
BECOMING INCARCERATED AND- WE
HAVE A RIGHT. TO HAVE THESE
KINDS OF CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
HOW FOLKS IDENTIFIED AND HOW
THEY WANT TO BE HOUSE. IF THERE
IS A PROBLEM THAT'S WHY WE HAVE
A LEGISLATIVE PROCESS THAT'S
WHY WE HAVE IMPLEMENTATION AND
ENFORCEMENT BUT AS I STATED AT
THE HEARING I'M CERTAINLY NOT
GOING TO BE ONE OF THE ONES
THAT STEPS IN FRONT OF
PROGRESS. AND MAKE ASSUMPTIONS
ABOUT HOW SOMETHING IS GOING TO
GO DOWN WITHOUT GIVING IMPROPER
SPACE TO SEE HOW IT CAN BE
IMPLEMENTED. A HELLO YEAH I
ACTUALLY HAVE A FOLLOW UP
QUESTION ON THAT AS WELL. SO
HUESO WE'RE GOING TO THE COMMON
WE'RE GOING TO JUST HAVE IT BE
COMMENTS SO YOU SHOULD.
DEFINITELY FEEL FREE TO ASK
YOUR QUESTIONS BUT JUST
RECOGNIZE THAT I WANT TO ALLOW
FOR ALL OF THE FOLKS WHO ARE
HERE TO SPEAK AND SO I MAY. I
RESERVE THE RIGHT NOT TO
RESPOND JUST SO THAT WE CAN A
RESPECT THE TIME ABOUT SHOE BUT
IN BE RESPECT THE TIME OF THE
OTHER FOLKS IN THE AUDIENCE
SURE YES ALSO ROBERT GREASY HE
MENTIONED EARLIER ABOUT
HOSTAGES ARE ARE VERY IT IS
VERY IMPORTANT IN THIS SPACE.
SPECIAL REGARDING WHAT HAPPENS
TO WOMEN IN PRISON AND THAT WE
NEED TO MAKE THIS PROCESS MORE
DATA DRIVEN AND VANESSA MARTIN.
HE ALSO MENTIONED HOW WE
BASICALLY TO BE SUPPORTING AND
NOTHING LESS COMMITTEES AND WE
TO COLLECT MORE DATA AND
ACCURATE DATA TO SERVE THEM
BETTER. THE ISSUE THE BILL IS
THAT OF THESE INMATES ARE BEING
HOUSED A CLASSIFIED BUT GENDER
IDENTITY AS OPPOSED TO BURKE
SIX AND ANY CRIMES THE
COMMISSION PRESENT. THEIR BEING
TRACKED AND CATALOG CONSISTENT
WITH A PERSON'S GENDER IDENTITY
FOR EXAMPLE A MODE FOR A
TRANSGENDER PERSON REYES A
FEMALE INMATE WILL BE
CLASSIFIED AS A FEMALE SEX
OFFENDER. THIS BILL WILL MAKE
IT IMPOSSIBLE TO TRACK HOW MANY
MTF TRANSIENT ENDED IN MAYES
ABUSE TREND I DID DE LOS TO
ASSAULT HER US OR TECH FROM
PRISONERS IT ALSO SECURE SYSTEM
IN AGE. OF SIX OF US AGAINST
WOMEN AND EROSION IS A BIT COIN.
TO DATE AND EVIDENCE AS A BASIS
OF PROTECTIONS. NOW. BOTH OF
THESE THINGS CAN BE RECORDED
LAST MONTH THE SCOTTISH
GOVERNMENT GREETED US SEX AND
GENDER IN. DATA WORKING GROUP.
PLEDGING TO DIFFERENTIATE
BETWEEN BIRTH CENTERED RIGHT
INTO THE- AND PUTTING BOTH OF
THEM IN DATA COLLECTION IN
ORDER TO. PROCESS HAVE
CONSISTENTLY MEASURE INEQUALITY
AND TACKLE DISCRIMINATION. AS
OF FEBRUARY OF THIS YEAR SINCE
IT'S CAÑADA IN PREPARATION FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY. ONE CENSUS
IT'S GOING TO RECORD SIX ENGINE
RIGHT INTO SEPARATELY. TO FILL
THE DATA GAP THAT AFFECTS LGBT
Q. INDIVIDUALS
DISPROPORTIONATELY. SO THE
QUESTION IS WHAT REMEDY IF ANY
DO YOU PROPOSE TO ENSURE THE-
INTEGRITY OF GOVERNMENT DATA.
WHICH IS A VITAL SOURCE OF
INFORMATION FOR ADVOCATES.
CONCERNED. FOR THE SAFETY FEW
AND MOST LIKE MANY OF YOU ON
THIS. HI MY NAME IS COBY LANDS
ADVOCATE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR WOMEN PRISONERS
AND SURVIVING PUNISHED THANK
YOU FOR HAVING THIS HEARING
THANK YOU FOR ALL OF YOUR
COMMENTS TODAY I'VE ALSO DEALT
SO MUCH RESPECT TO THOSE WHO
EXPERIENCE INCARCERATION ARE
STILL HERE SPEAKING ABOUT AN
ADVOCATING FOR CHANGE I HAVEN'T
DIRECTLY BUT I'VE BEEN DOZEN
PEOPLE PRISONS FOR ABOUT TWENTY
YEARS AND HAVE EXPERIENCE
SECONDHAND SO MUCH OF THE
TRAUMA OF USE THAT OCCURS IN
THERE AND ALSO WHAT BRINGS
PEOPLE TO PRISON AND WE SPEND
MOST OF OUR TIME FIGHTING TO.
TO SUPPORT WILL TO SURVIVE
THEIR TIME DURING TERRIBLE
CONDITIONS BUT ALSO TO ACHIEVE
RELEASE AND SO SOME OF THAT IS
THROUGH SOME THE RE SENTENCING
MECHANISMS THAT THAT SOME FROM
THE DA'S OFFICE MENTIONED SO I
JUST WANTED TO SAY IN THIS
MOMENT SINCE BOTH OF YOU HERE
AND ESPECIALLY YOUR HERE IN
THAT UNIT WE COULD REALLY USE
MORE LEADERSHIP FROM THE DA'S
OFFICE AROUND ELEVEN SEVENTY D.
READ AND SING POSSIBILITIES.
AND THERE IS THERE WAS A BILL
PASSED RATE AB TWO NINE FORTY
TWO WHICH GIVES THE IS ACTUAL
AUTHORITY TO INITIATE RESENTING
FOR PEOPLE POST CONVICTION AND
IT'S ONLY BEEN ONE PERSON WE
KNOW OF SO FAR STATEWIDE WHO'S
ACTUALLY BEEN REASONS THROUGH
THAT POWER THAT YOU ALL NOW SO
JUST HERE TO SAY WE REALLY
WANTS. LEADERSHIP THERE WE CAN
SUPPORT IT WERE THERE SO MANY
PEOPLE THAT WE ALL WORK WITH
MANY OF US IN THE ROOM WHO WE
WOULD REALLY LIKE TO SUPPORT
YOU TO TAKE LEADERSHIP TO
MACHINE WE SENTENCING AND THE
OTHER THING I WANT TO SAY IS
THAT THE TWO RECENT
PROSECUTIONS THAT A WITNESS IN
LA ON ONE FOR A WOMAN WHO
DEFENDED HERSELF IN AN ABUSIVE
SITUATION THE PROSPECTORS IN
COMPTON AS WE SEE EVERYWHERE
WE'RE INTENT ON MAKING SURE
THAT SHE SPENT THE REST OF HER
LIFE IN PRISON FOR TO SOFTEN A
TERRIBLE SITUATION SO THE FORMS
ARE ON DOMESTIC VIOLENCE HAVE
BEEN. HAVE HAD ALMOST NO IMPACT
IN A POSITIVE WAY THAT WE'VE
SEEN AS A GROUP THAT DEFENDS
SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC AND
SEXUAL VIOLENCE WERE BEING
PROSECUTED AND CRIMINALIZED SO
WE IT. THERE'S A LOT TO SAY
ABOUT THAT AND THEN ANOTHER
YOUNG WOMAN WHO. SHE WAS IN
QUESTION IS A YOUNG PERSON'S
BUT MOST WERE TIMES SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT. SHOULD THIS IS
WHAT SHE NEEDED AND IT WAS
REFUSE SO EVEN WHEN THOSE
RESOURCES EXIST. AND EVEN WHEN
WE ARE THERE IN COURT FIGHTING
RIGHT TO SAY YOU DIDN'T LIKE.
THIS SELF DEFENSE ISN'T
SUPPOSED TO BE NOT A CRIME
RIGHT BUT WHEN IT COMES TO
BLACK WOMEN IN PARTICULAR. ON
IT THAT IS NOT THE CASE. SO
THERE'S SO MANY THINGS WE CAN
DO TO INTERRUPT SOME OF THE
SENTENCING PROCESS SEES.
ANOTHER MAIN ONE IS AROUND
ACCOMPLICES WOMEN IN PARTICULAR
CHARGED AS ACCOMPLICES. FELONY
MURDER ONLY TOUCHED. ON THAT
PROBLEM RIGHT THE FELONY MURDER
REFORM FOR ACCOMPLICES THAT WE
WORKED ON. SO JUST AS A PLEASE
USE THIS IS A RESOURCE WE HAVE
A GAZILLION IDEAS. THAT ARE
INFORMED BY PEOPLE WHO ARE
CURRENTLY INCARCERATED IN
FORMING FRUSTRATED. I'M WE
WOULD LOVE TO HELP THINK.
BEFORE YOU LEAVE. WITH RESPECT
TO THE ELEVEN SEVENTY THESE
YEAH SO. WHAT I WOULD SAY IS
THAT OUR OFFICE DOES IT.
DOESN'T KNOW WHICH CASES TO
FOCUS ON SO YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO BRING YOUR HAVE TO
ORGANIZE TO BRING THOSE CASES
TO OUR ATTENTION WE WOULD LOVE
TO. IT WILL MAKE SURE TO THREE.
I ALSO WANT TO MENTION THAT
TOMORROW AT MY DISTRICT OFFICE
FROM NINE TO ONE ARE
LEGISLATIVE TEAM WILL BE THERE
HEARING DISTRICT BILL IDEA SO
IF YOU HAVE IDEAS IDEAS FOR NEW
LEGISLATION COME ON DOWN FROM
NINE TO ONE SO YOU CAN TALK
WITH OUR LEGISLATIVE STAFF
THAT'S DOWN HERE FROM THE
CAPITOL OFFICE. YEAH I THINK SO
MUCH FOR THAT AND FOR IN THIS
TOGETHER IN THE DIALOGUE THANK
YOU GUYS FOR BEING HERE AND
OTHER WOMEN WARRIORS THAT HERE
LIKE THIS VERY POWERFUL. MY
NAME IS JOHN MATTHEWS I WORK
FOR THE JUSTICE COLLABORATIVE
WORKING A COUPLE JUST REFORM
AROUND THE COUNTRY AND REALLY
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN
CREATE A MORE HUMANE. JUSTICE
SYSTEM WAS ALSO FEDERAL
PROSECUTOR BEFORE AND SO MY
QUESTION IS HAS THAT WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT. THE CULTURE AND
I YOUR SEX SHOULD YOU KNOW
WASN'T CONSIDERED POPULAR FIRST
QUESTION IS LIKE HOW DO WE
CHANGE THAT. CULTURE RIGHT MAKE
IT YOU KNOW I FOUND THAT. SIX
THAT'S WITH THE FINE BY
CONVICTION RATES AND- THE
SEXIEST CASES WERE THE ONES
THAT WERE YOU KNOW LIKE. THE
RESIGNATIONS AND GOING TO TRIAL
AND HAPPINESS SO LIKE. HOW
COULD CHANGE THAT CULTURE. SO
THAT THERE'S MORE UNITS DOING
THE WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING AND
WHAT YOU INTERESTED IN THAT
WORK. I'M AND ALSO TO YOUR
POINT ABOUT PROBATION. AND I
HEARD IT SOUND LIKE THE MOST
THAT WAS PRE PLEA OR START
CLOSELY. AND SOMEONE AND WHAT
EFFORTS ARE BEING MADE. TO KEEP
PEOPLE OUT OF THE SYSTEM. YOU
KNOW PREVIOUSLY AND. IN YES THE
PROBATION ID LIKE AT HOW WE HOW
WE THINK ABOUT SHRINKING THE
SYSTEM BECAUSE EVEN WHEN IT
COMES TO RESOURCES. AND IT'S
HAPPENING WITH THOSE RESOURCES
ARE GOING RALLY I LIKE THE
IDEA. WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
WORKING WITH MANY ORGANIZATIONS
RALLY HOW CAN WE DIVERT. MORE
MONEY TO ORGANIZATIONS THAT TRY
TO KEEP PEOPLE OUT OF THE
SYSTEM SO. THANK YOU. I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO HAVE THESE
CONVERSATIONS THAT MAKES ME
FEEL GOOD TO BE HERE BECAUSE-
YOU KNOW YOU GUYS THOUGHT
ENOUGH OF ME TO INVITE ME AND
MY OFFICE THOUGHT ENOUGH OF ME
TO SEND ME. SO I THINK IT'S
JUST PUBLICITY AND OTHER THING
TOO IS I REALLY DON'T CARE WHAT
MY OFFICE THINGS ABOUT ME. I
DON'T CARE WHAT PEOPLE THINK
ABOUT ME I SO THE RECORD EVERY
DAY AND TRY TO DO MY BEST JOB
THAT I POSSIBLY CAN. I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO HAVE A DA
THAT SUPPORTS TREATMENT. JACKIE
LACEY WA HAS BEEN SUPPORTIVE OF
TREATMENT SINCE THE VERY
BEGINNING WHEN I FIRST CAME
DOWNTOWN THERE IS A SUPERVISOR
WHO CAME TO ME AND SAID YOU
KNOW IT'S TOO BAD YOU CAME
DOWNTOWN TO DO THE TREATMENT
COURT BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO
CLOSE SOON. AND I WAS LIKE OH
OKAY WHATEVER. AND THEN THE
NEXT THING I KNEW THERE WAS.
MONEY AND THERE WAS AN
EXPANSION OF THE TREATMENT
COURTS. AND SO. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT HIGHER UP IN OUR
OFFICE SUPPORT THE TREATMENT
COURTS AND GIVE GIVE US RESPECT
AND THEN. THROUGH THAT JACKIE
LACEY FORMED A NEW UNIT IT'S
CALLED THE MENTAL HEALTH
DIVISION. AT MY HEAD DEPUTY.
DAY GOES OUT INTO THE COMMUNITY
AND WE DO MENTAL HEALTH
DIVERSION. SO YOU APPLY FOR
MENTAL HEALTH VERSION OF YOUR
DEFENDANT. AND THEN THAT UNIT
REVIEWS IT AND DECIDES WHETHER
OR NOT THE DA'S POSITION IS
APPROPRIATE OR NOT APPROPRIATE
YOU KNOW BECAUSE SOME DA'S
MIGHT DIFFER. AND I THINK A LOT
OF IT TOO IS. PERSONALITY
DRIVEN ABOUT THE JUDGE WHO MADE
THAT DECISION NOT TO SEND
SOMEONE TO TREATMENT. YOU KNOW
THERE'S A THERE'S A CULTURE AND
THE JUDGE THERE YOU ARE.
THERE'S A CULTURE IN THE YOU
KNOW. IN THE JUDICIAL SYSTEM
WHETHER OR NOT TREATMENT IS
JUST A- AN EASY WAY OUT. YOU
KNOW IT I KNOW IT'S NOT. YOU
KNOW I'VE SEEN IT IT'S HARD BUT
YOU SAID FIVE YEARS PROBATION.
IT'S HARD. I MEAN IT'S A LONG
TIME TO BE ON PROBATION IT BE
EASIER FOR YOU TO JUST TAKE
YOUR JAIL TIME AND GO ON I
MEAN. WHEN PEOPLE COME TO
TREATMENT I HOPE. THAT THEY ARE
EDUCATED ON WHAT THEY'RE
GETTING THEIR SINCE THEMSELVES
INTO. NO EYES WIDE OPEN AND IT
IS HARD OF IT IS SO HARD. BUT
MAYBE IN THE LONG RUN IT'S
BETTER FOR THEM I'M NOT SURE
SOMETIMES I LIVE WITH THE FACT
THAT SOME PEOPLE. GET INTO
TREATMENT AND THEN DE I KNOW I
HAVE MY OWN GUILT. ABOUT THAT
TO WHAT HAPPENS IF I HAD
SOMETHING TO PRISON WITH BABY
ALIVE HOW WOULD THEIR FAMILY
FEEL. NO BUT YOU KNOW WHAT I
HAVE THAT I HAVE THAT
EXPERIENCE NOW. AND I HAVE MORE
THAN ONE SO IT'S TRAUMATIZING
SO ANYWAY. MY OWN TRAUMA. US
AIR CONDITIONER ON AN ADVOCATE
WITH CALIFORNIA COOL
TEMPERAMENT PRISONER AND I'M OF
THE YOUNG WOMAN'S FREEDOM
CENTER AND- ONE OF THINGS ON MY
PLATE TO CONTINUE TO INSPIRE ME
WITH THEIR- COURAGE AND POWER
IN THE LEADERSHIP THERE
PROVIDING THAT ONLY REALLY THEY
CAN PROVIDE SO THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE. HERE THAT. YOU KNOW
I THINK ALL OF ANALYSTS ON THE
FIRST PANEL. THE CZECHO ALSO
TALKED ABOUT HOW TRAUMATIZING
THE SYSTEM IS AND HOW MUCH IT
PUNISHES PEOPLE FOR HISTORIES
OF TRAUMA AND I AM. I MEAN. SO
HOW DO WE. AND ALSO HOW MANY
PEOPLE ON THAT PANEL TALKED
ABOUT WHEN THEY TALK ABOUT
THEIR HISTORY OF TRAUMA OR TALK
ABOUT SELF DEFENSE THAT THAT'S
USED AGAINST THEM. IN AN IN
SENTENCING AND REFUSING PAROLE
BECAUSE IT'S SEEN AS A REFUSAL
TO TAKE ACCOUNTABILITY AND SO.
YOU KNOW IN ADDITION TO THE
MANY OTHER THINGS WE NEED TO DO
AND THE FACT THAT THE SYSTEM IS
DESIGNED TO CONTINUE TO
TRAUMATIZE PEOPLE HOW. HOW ARE
WE. WHAT IS THE FIGHT SO THAT
TRAUMA CAN BE CONSIDERED. AND
NOT SEEN AS A LACK OF
ACCOUNTABILITY AND- HAD A
SECOND FORCED AND HOW DO YOU.
WHAT'S THE LEGISLATION. THAT
PUTS MONEY REAL REALLY TAKES
MONEY OUT OF THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND PUTS IT
INTO. ADDRESSING SOME OF THAT
HISTORY'S SO LIKE WHAT ARE THE
MECHANISMS. TO STOP THAT. AND
TO EDUCATE OR HOLD JUDGES.
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S. AROUND
TRAUMA AND WHAT IT MEANS TO BE
UNDER THE POWER OF SOMEONE WHO
ABUSES HE IS SO WHAT ARE SOME
OF THOSE MECHANISMS THAT WE CAN
CREATE THROUGH LEGISLATION. HI
MY NAME IS INGRID. I HAVE A
QUESTION FOR THE ALTERNATE
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE AS
WELL AS THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY.
FOR THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY WILL
WERE THINKING IN TERMS OF
SENTENCING IN THE CASES THAT WE
TRY ARE YOU AWARE THAT THERE
ARE FORTY EIGHT HUNDRED
COLLATERAL CONSEQUENCES TO A
FELONY CONVICTION BEFORE PERSON
PLEASE GUILTY. AND IF YOU ARE
AWARE OF THIS ARE YOU A ARE YOU
LETTING YOUR CLIENTS AND ALL
THAT. THEY WILL THEY WILL FACE
THESE CONSEQUENCES ONCE THEY
TAKE UP THIS FELONY CONVICTION
AND THEY'RE RELEASED. AND THAT
I WILL BE LOCKED OUT OF ALL OF
THESE ALL OF THESE SERVICES
WHEN THEY COME HOME. SEE WHEN
YOU SAY CLIENT YOU'RE REFERRING
TO THE MISCHIEVOUS I'M TOM I'M
SPEAKING IN TERMS OF SENTENCING
AND I'M ALSO SPEAKING IN TERMS
OF CLIENTS. DOESN'T MATTER. I
WANT YOU TO GO FIRST AND THEN I
THINK WE HAVE ABOUT WHAT FIVE
OR SEVEN MORE MINUTES BEFORE
WILL HAVE TO OFFICIALLY END SO
THAT. BET YOU THAT CAN PREPARE
FOR THEIR SEVEN O'CLOCK EVEN.
YES I. TO THE BUTTON I ACTUALLY
HELPED WRITE THE BOOK ON
JUVENILE COLLATERAL
CONSEQUENCES JUNE WOULD YOU TO
PATIENT I'VE TRAINED LAWYERS
AND JUDGES AND EVERYWHERE
EVERYBODY I COULD ABOUT THAT
AND SO BAILABLE ON A ON A
WEBSITE CALLED PJ DC DOT ORG
AND THERE'S NO WAY I COULD
POSSIBLY INFORMED THE CLIENTS
OF EVERY POSSIBLE COLLATERAL
CONSEQUENCE BECAUSE THERE ARE
SO MANY IN YOUR SO RIGHT BUT WE
DO TRY TO HIT THE MAJOR ONES.
AND WE ARE ALSO TRYING TO
MINIMIZE AND REDUCE THE
COLLATERAL CONSEQUENCES WORKING
ON LEGISLATION ON OUT SO IT
IT'S JUST TERRIFIC PROGRAM I'M
IN A PROBLEM IN KIDS WHO A
PLATE TO CERTAIN MISDEMEANOR
BATTERY OFFENSES CAN NOT
POSSESS A WEAPON UNTIL THE AGE
OF THIRTY AND THAT CAN PREVENT
THEM FROM ENTERING INTO THE
MILITARY YOU KNOW SO THAT'S
THAT'S JUST ONE OF HUNDREDS OF
CONSEQUENCES GET THE CONSIDER.
OKAY KID DID YOU HEAR ME. OK.
BUT I APPRECIATE YOUR- I VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR POINT. WE
E. UNDER BY LAW WOULD HAVE TO
INFORM ANYBODY WHO IS ENTERING
INTO A PLEASE WE HAVE TO INFORM
THEM OF THE MAJOR CONSEQUENCES
BEFORE BEFORE JUDGE WILL
ACTUALLY TAKE A PLEA I THINK
KIM ALL TELL YOU THAT. ON OUR
SIDE WE'RE GETTING MORE
EDUCATED ABOUT ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT COLLATERAL
CONSEQUENCES. BUT TO BE FRANK
WITH YOU WHEN WE'RE TRAINED AND
THE MAJORITY OF THE PEOPLE WHO
WORK IN THE DA'S OFFICE THERE
TRYING CASES AND SO. THEIR
FOCUS IS A IN IS AN ON
COLLATERAL CONDITION ARE
CONSEQUENCES AND SO THERE HAS
TO BE AS KIM POINTED OUT A
CULTURE CHANGE WHERE THE WHOLE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM IS
TAKING INTO ACCOUNT THE FACT
THAT IF YOU PLEAD GUILTY TO A
CERTAIN OFFENSE. YOU CAN'T
BECOME A TEACHER HE PLEAD
GUILTY A CERTAIN THE OFFENSE
YOU CAN'T BE A THE BUS DRIVER
IF YOU PLEAD GUILTY TO A
CERTAIN EVENTS YOU CAN'T BE A
FISHING LICENSE SECURITY GUARD
SEE THESE ARE ALL THINGS THAT A
LOT OF PEOPLE WHO WORK IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM FOR A
LONG TIME I. DON'T KNOW AND SO
IT IT'S A GOOD THING THAT
YOU'RE BRING IT UP IT'S GOOD
THING THAT'S BEING BROUGHT UP
IN THIS HEARING BECAUSE I THINK.
NOT ONLY CAN IT BE ADDRESSED
FROM THE LEGISLATURE VIEW I
THINK IT HAS TO BE TALKED ABOUT
BROADLY WITHIN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND I THINK
THAT'S HAPPENING NOT AS FAST AS
MOST PEOPLE WOULD LIKE IT BUT I
THINK IT IS HAPPENING. SO I CAN
OFFER A SOLUTION I CAN COME
DOWN TO YOUR OFFICE AND TRAIN
YOUR WHOLE STAFF ON THE FORTY
EIGHT HUNDRED COLLADO
CONSEQUENCES TO A FELONY
CONVICTION SO THAT PEOPLE CAN
UNDERSTAND THEIR RIGHTS AND
THEY CAN FIGHT HARDER FOR THEIR
CASES AND THEY WON'T BE. ENOUGH
FOR THEIR FAMILIES AND THEIR
CHILDREN PLACED IN DCFS SYSTEM.
INGRID I INVITE YOU TO COME TO
MY. OFFICE TO OKAY I ONLY
HANDLE JUVENILE BUT I. YEAH I
JUST HAVE A STATEMENT YEAH I'M
APRIL. AND SO. THE THING THAT I
REALLY WANT TO CHALLENGE
EVERYBODY IN THIS ROOM TODAY I
APPRECIATE HOW PROGRESSIVE YOU
GUYS ARE. BUT THE LANGUAGE THAT
I'VE BEEN HEARING HERE'S BEEN
OFFENDER AN INMATE. AND A LOT
OF PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM ARE
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND THE LABELS
THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE PLACED ON
THAT'S REPLACE BACK IN SLAVERY
DAYS LATE. ABOLISHED SLAVERY
AND SO THEY THEN STARTED
LABELING THAT'S A CRIMINALIZING
US BECAUSE THEY NEEDED US TO
HAVE THE THEY HAVE FREE LABOR.
AND SO I REALLY WANT TO
CHALLENGE EVERYBODY TODAY AND
THEY THINK ABOUT. WHEN THEY DO
TALK ABOUT ONE INCARCERATED
PEOPLE INCARCERATED PEOPLE HOW
DO YOU TALK ABOUT THEM ARE THE
INMATES. ARE THE OFFENDERS NO.
ONE THE CARD FOR THE PEOPLE
THERE ACROSS WHERE PEOPLE THEIR
PEOPLE THAT ARE EXPERIENCING.
DIFFERENT STAGES OF THE SYSTEM
SINCE ARE JUST REALLY WANT TO
CHALLENGE YOU. WHEN YOU ADDRESS
THESE PEOPLE AND HOW YOU DECIDE
TO DISCUSS THIS CAN YOU PLEASE
NOT CALL LIST INMATES AND
OFFENDERS BECAUSE A VERY
DEGRADING. AND YOU'RE PLACING
LABELS ON. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
APRIL SO WITH THAT. I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF YOU ALL FOR
SHOWING UP ON THIS. THURSDAY OR
WEDNESDAY WEDNESDAY. TO TALK
ABOUT THIS ISSUE PEOPLE DON'T
UNDERSTAND HOW PERVASIVE HOW
PERVASIVE THE INCARCERATION IN
THE JUDICIAL SYSTEM IS IN SO
MANY OF OUR LIVES THERE IS A
REASON WHY IN NEW YORK THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT CLOSING DOWN
RYKER'S ISLAND NOT BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE ANY MORE
INCARCERATED FOLKS BUT BECAUSE
EVERY SINGLE PERSON FROM THE
MEDICAL DOCTORS TO THE FOLKS
WHO ARE INCARCERATED TO THE
VISITORS HAVE BEEN TRAUMATIZED.
TO SUCH AN EXTENT THAT THEY
KNOW THAT THIS IS NO LONGER A
VIABLE OPTION AND SO THESE
SERIES OF CONVERSATIONS PUTTING
WOMEN IN THE SPOTLIGHT. OUR
ABOUT ASKING US HOW WE WANT TO
LIVE I WENT WITH THE DELEGATION
TO NORWAY TO LOOK AT THEIR
STATE PRISONS THAT WAS
TRAUMATIZING TO SEE HOW
DIFFERENTLY THEY TREAT THEIR
OWN AND THEY SAY. THE COURT IS
WHERE YOU PUNISH. THE PRISON IS
WHERE YOU REHABILITATE SO THAT
PEOPLE CAN BECOME BETTER
NEIGHBORS. IT IS NOT PUNITIVE
IT IS NOT DE HUMOR TIME DE
HUMANIZING. IT IS NOT
DEMORALIZING. IT IS ABOUT
HEALING PEOPLE SO THEY CAN COME
OUT WHOLE SO THAT THEY CAN
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT'S LIKE TO BE
IN OUR LOVING RELATIONSHIP TO
BE IN A JOB WHERE THERE'S
DIGNITY TO WALK DOWN THE STREET
AND FEEL WHOLE. AND WE TAKE
APART HUMANITY PIECE BY PIECE
WITH EVERY STEP IN THIS SYSTEM
FROM HOW WE OVER MONITOR FOLKS
THAT AND HOW WE OVER CHARGE
THEM TO THEN HOW WE OVER
SENTENCE THEM TO THEN HOW WE RE
INCARCERATE AND THEN HOW WE
DENY ACCESS TO REHABILITATION
THAT PIPELINE HAS SO MANY
TENTACLES. THAT DESTROYED
FAMILIES AND HOPE AND SO I AM
CONTINUING TO INVITE ALL OF US
TO BE PART OF THIS BECAUSE IF
WE'RE HERE WE'RE PART OF THE
SOLUTION YOU'RE NOT CALL TO THE
PANEL YOU DID NOT SIT IN THE
SEATS. BECAUSE WE THINK YOUR
PROBLEM. YOU HAVE A SKILL SET
OR A TRAUMA OR A STORY. THAT
WILL HELP SOLVE THIS. AND IT
TAKES US ALL TO CONTINUE TO
TALK ABOUT THE TRUTHS OF THIS
SYSTEM IF WE WANT TO SEE A
DIFFERENT FUTURE SO I THINK YOU
I WANT TO THANK THIS PANEL HERE
AS I SAID FOR YOUR COURAGE AND
FOR GOING TO WORK EVERY DAY
BECAUSE I AM SURE THAT YOU ARE
DEALING WITH YOUR OWN TRAUMAS.
IN THE SYSTEM. AND I WANT TO
THANK THE FIRST PANEL FOR YOUR
COURAGE FOR YOUR WISDOM FOR
YOUR INSIGHT FOR YOUR STRENGTH
FOR YOUR HEART FOR YOUR
PERSEVERANCE. AND FOR YOUR
WORDS AND I WANT TO THANK THOSE
WHO JOINED US TO LIVE STREAM
AND THOSE AT THAT SHIVA. FOR
OPENING UP YOUR HERE YEARS IN
YOUR HEARTS TO THIS VERY
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION SO THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU WHEN WE
WILL SEE YOU IN FEBRUARY